Hi. Hi. It's Smartless, everybody. You want to go around and introduce yourselves? We haven't done it in a long time. We haven't. Yeah, go ahead. I'm Sean Hay.
嗨。嗨。大家好，这里是 Smartless。你们要不要轮流自我介绍一下？我们好久没这么做了。确实好久没做了。对，来吧。我是肖恩·海。
I'm Sean Hayes. I'm Will Arnett. And I'm Jason Vae. What's your porn name, Sean? Middle name and street you grew up on. Patrick Valley. Patrick Valley. That's actually pretty good.
我是肖恩·海斯。我是威尔·阿奈特。我是杰森·贝。肖恩，你的色情片名字叫什么？中间名加上你长大的那条街。帕特里克·瓦利。帕特里克·瓦利。这其实还挺不错的。
That's pretty porny. JB, what about you? It is porny. Kent Emerson. Kent Emerson. That's a good one. That's a good one. That's a good one.
这挺有色情片的感觉的。JB，你呢？确实很有色情片的感觉。肯特·爱默生。肯特·爱默生。这个不错。这个不错。这个不错。
That's a good one. That's a good one. That's a good one. Patrick Valley. Patrick Valley. That's actually pretty good. That's pretty porny. JB, what about you? It is porny. Kent Emerson. No way. Sounds like he's got a strong mustache, right? Guess what?
这个不错。这个不错。这个不错。帕特里克·瓦利。帕特里克·瓦利。这其实还挺不错的。这挺有色情片的感觉的。JB，你呢？确实很有色情片的感觉。肯特·爱默生。没门。听起来他留着一把很浓密的胡子，对吧？你猜怎么着？
Mine is Emerson Edgar. Oh! Oh my gosh. Wow, did you guys do a porn together? Are we gonna do porn together? Yeah. Let's do it after an all new smart list. Okay.
我的是爱默生·埃德加。哦！哦天哪。哇，你们俩一起拍过色情片吗？我们待会儿要一起拍色情片吗？对啊。全新 Smartless 节目结束后我们就去拍。好。
Smart List. Sean, when we had dinner Saturday night, all of us at our friend's house in New York. We did. And then at a certain point, Downey was wearing that shirt, that t-shirt that he sort of wore for JB. And he said, I want to give it to you. And he said, okay, so let's switch now. So all of a sudden in the middle of this dinner party, JB and Downey stand up and they go
Smartless。肖恩，上周六晚上我们在纽约朋友家吃晚饭的时候，我们所有人都在。我们确实在那。然后在某个时刻，唐尼穿着那件T恤，那件他特地为JB穿的T恤。然后他说，我想把它送给你。然后他说，好，那我们现在就换吧。所以突然之间在这个晚宴的正中间，JB和唐尼站起来，然后他们说
tarps off and switch. I didn't see that. Yeah, a little top swap. Wait, but you had a Sex Pistols t-shirt on. Right, that was his, he gave it to me. Downey walked in with that. Oh, I thought that's what you showed up with. No, I was just in a generic blue tee, a nice tee.
脱掉上衣然后交换。我没看到那个。对，就互换了一下上衣。等等，但你当时穿着一件“性手枪”乐队的T恤。对，那是他的，他送给我的。唐尼穿着那件走进来的。哦，我还以为那是你自带的呢。不，我本来只是穿着一件普通的蓝色T恤，一件不错的T恤。
Sure. And I said, you know what? Who was I? Robert, we're looking for beautiful vintage rock T-shirts for this idiot character I'm playing. And man, that looks like a good one. And he had the sex pistols on? Yeah, and he goes, oh yeah, I paid a lot of money for this.
当然。然后我说，你知道吗？我是谁？罗伯特，我们在为我正在演的一个白痴角色寻找漂亮的复古摇滚T恤。天哪，那件看起来真不错。他身上穿着“性手枪”的吗？对，然后他说，哦对啊，我为这个花了很多钱。
And he told me the number, I was like, good lord. And he said, you want it? For a T-shirt? He paid a lot of money for a T-shirt? Oh, buddy. I said, yeah, I want it. He goes, well here, let paid a lot of money for a t-shirt? Oh buddy. I said, yeah I want it. He goes, well here, let's step over here and I'll give it to you.
然后他告诉我那个数字，我当时想，天哪。然后他说，你想要吗？就为了一件T恤？他花了很多钱买了一件T恤？哦，老兄。我说，对，我想要。他说，好吧，来，花了很多钱买了一件T恤？哦，老兄。我说，对，我想要。他说，好吧，来，我们到这边来，我把它给你。
I said, no, you're what? And then he said, yeah, yeah, no. I said, well we don't need to step anywhere. Let's just do it right here. Jason. So we just, a little top swap and now I'm going to work it into the show but we're trying to get clearance on Sex Pistols
我说，不，你什么？然后他说，对，对，不。我说，我们不需要去任何地方。就在这儿换吧。杰森。所以我们就，简单换了个上衣，现在我正打算把它穿到节目里，不过我们正在争取“性手枪”乐队的授权
and if we don't get clearance on it then I'm just gonna work it into the show, but we're trying to get clearance on Sex Pistols. And if we don't get clearance on it, then I'm just gonna put it in my wardrobe, you know, my closet at home. Wait for Danny to forget. Yes, but I can get you a thousand of those for $5. You can get me a thousand t-shirts for $5? Oh, like vintage old, like 70s, 80s, 90s bands. Where are you getting these from?
如果我们拿不到授权的话，那我就把它穿到节目里，不过我们正在争取“性手枪”乐队的授权。如果我们拿不到授权的话，那我就把它放进我的衣橱里，你知道的，我家里的衣橱。等唐尼忘了这事。对，不过我可以花5美元给你弄一千件那种衣服。你能花5美元给我弄一千件T恤？哦，就像复古老式的那种，70年代、80年代、90年代的乐队T恤。你从哪弄来的这些？
You just get them online. Oh, okay. Or in vintage shops. I just went, I went vintage shopping with Franny yesterday because she wanted to do some shopping here in New York. And while she was looking at her stuff, I went looking at the old rock t-shirts there in this incredible store called Metropolis down on Broadway.
你直接在网上买就行。哦，好吧。或者在复古店里。我昨天刚跟弗拉尼去逛了复古店，因为她想在纽约买点东西。当她在看她自己的东西时，我在百老汇那家叫大都会的不可思议的店里看那些老摇滚T恤。
And God, they got a great site. And I bought five great old rock concert t-shirts and man, they're expensive. You know, you should have asked, you know Alessandra had a t-shirt business, this is not a bit, for years. Really? Yeah, she has like a warehouse full of
天哪，他们的网站真棒。我买了几件很棒的老摇滚演唱会T恤，天哪，它们可贵了。你知道的，你本该问问的，亚历山德拉做过T恤生意，这可不是开玩笑，做了好多年。真的吗？对，她有一个仓库装满了
incredible vintage tees that she procured over the years. But boxes upon boxes upon boxes. Why is she holding onto them? Why does she sell them to places like Trump? It was hard for her to, well, because they don't do the business anymore, so they got to figure out what they're going to do with the... Assets. With the stock. Yeah, yeah.
这些年她搜罗的各种不可思议的复古T恤。一箱又一箱又一箱。她为什么一直留着它们？她为什么不把它们卖给像特鲁姆这样的地方？她很难，嗯，因为他们不干这行了，所以他们得想想怎么处理这些……资产。这些库存。对，对。
Well, I can take a lot of that off her hands. Yeah, same. Me and Sean will help her out. As long as it's in New York, you can take a look at it. Great. Where is she at? Is she still here? She is. Did she come back with you? No, she is. She's there. I'll tell her to call you after.
好吧，我可以帮她接手很大一部分。对，我也是。我和肖恩会帮她的。只要还在纽约，你就可以去看一看。太好了。她在哪？她还在吗？在的。她跟你一起回来的吗？没有，她在。她在那。我待会儿让她给你打电话。
Great. JB, I don't know if you know this, Sean's had two hours sleep, he had another AFib in the middle of the night, true story. I just got home. And had to go to Mount Sinai. Just got home an hour ago. Did you OD on gummies?
太好了。JB，我不知道你知不知道这件事，肖恩只睡了两个小时，他半夜又发了一次房颤，千真万确。我刚到家。不得不去西奈山医院。一个小时前刚到家。你是不是软糖吃过量了？
No. So now I don't, you know what I did? What'd you do? You guys are gonna laugh. I got it. I'm not. Did they have a sale on butter pecan ice cream? What happened?
没有。所以现在我不会，你知道我做了什么吗？你做什么了？你们一定会笑的。我懂了。我才不呢。他们奶油山核桃冰淇淋在大促销吗？怎么了？
And you went crazy? I was walking down the street and I hailed a cab and I ran to get the cab and it just triggered it. You can't run? Okay, what you need is a nice aerobics class, I think is what I'm figuring out. No, I'm gonna get the ablation where they go in and they fry a little part of your heart out.
然后你疯了？我走在街上，叫了一辆出租车，然后跑过去打车，结果就把这毛病给诱发了。你不能跑吗？好吧，我觉得你需要的是一节不错的有氧操课，我是这么想的。不，我要去做消融手术，他们会进去把我心脏的一小部分烧掉。
You've heard what that is, right? No, I've also heard about just like a step class, or a stationary bike. When do you work on your fucking endurance? No, I have endurance. I should clearly not. You're running after a cab and you end up in the hospital. I know. But Sean, you should go into your pantry with a flamethrower and do an ablation on all the
你听说过那是什么吧？没有，我还听说过什么踏步班或者固定单车。你什么时候去练练你那该死的耐力？不，我有耐力。我显然不该这样的。你追着出租车跑，结果进了医院。我知道。不过肖恩，你应该拿着喷火器走进你的储藏室，把里面的所有
food that's in there. Listen, hey, Glass House, let's not talk about pantries. Yeah. Okay? JB loves coming into my pantry. It's so, but here's what happens is he, every single time he comes in, he goes in, he goes in the pantry and then comes out and he's like,
食物都给做个消融手术。听着，玻璃房子里的人，咱们别聊储藏室了。对。好吗？JB很喜欢走进我的储藏室。这太……但情况是这样的，他每次进来，他都会进去，走进储藏室然后出来，然后就会说：
you got a lot of stuff, what are you gonna eat? As he's stuffing his stupid fat face. Did I ever show you the picture I took of your freezer, or sorry, your ice cream fridge? Yes, I love it. So you got one side with soda and food, and then the other side, which is supposed to be a freezer, is just basically like a repository for ice cream.
你这有这么多东西，你到底要吃哪个？同时他还在往他那蠢笨肥硕的嘴里塞东西。我有没有给你看我拍的你的冰冰箱，或者抱歉，你的冰淇淋冰箱的照片？有啊，我太喜欢了。所以你有一边放着苏打水和食物，然后另一边，本该是冷冻柜的地方，基本上就是个冰淇淋仓库。
Yeah. It's all that sweet, sweet, sweet McConnell ice cream, which I adore, and I like Haagen-Dazs too. Here comes more. Haagen-Dazs is the best. Haagen-Dazs, I'll probably... Haagen hug and does I'll hug you guys looking for free ice cream I'm just gonna sorry I'm gonna put a little wet I'm gonna put an address a link they can click on at the end Jay
对。全都是那些甜美无比的麦康奈尔冰淇淋，我可太喜欢了，我也很喜欢哈根达斯。又来一个。哈根达斯是最好的。哈根达斯，我可能会……哈根，拥抱并……如果你俩在找免费冰淇淋，我马上就，抱歉，我会在最后放一点微湿的，我会放一个地址，一个他们可以点击的链接，杰。
You know why I love hog and eyes vanilla ice cream because it's only milk eggs cream and sugar and that's it and Vanilla sometimes you just pour those ingredients in your mouth right stick your head in the freezer Just make it a little mouthwash with pour those ingredients in your mouth, right, and they stick your head in the freezer. Just make it in your mouth. And do a little mouth wash with them. Make it in your mouth, pour it in, they stick your head in. Oh god, Jason's busy over there. I'm lacing my new shoes.
你知道我为什么喜欢哈根达斯香草冰淇淋吗？因为它只有牛奶、鸡蛋、奶油和糖，就这些。还有香草。有时候你直接把这些配料倒进嘴里就行了，对吧？把头扎进冰箱里。用它们漱漱口，直接把这些配料倒进嘴里，对吧，然后把头扎进冰箱。直接在嘴里搅拌。用它们漱漱口。直接在嘴里搅拌，倒进去，然后把头扎进去。哦天哪，杰森那边正忙着呢。我在系我的新鞋带呢。
So, Franny, maple, Franny got me into a t-shirt addiction. Maple's got me into really expensive tennis shoes. Yeah, those are those. And now I can't stop. Yeah. They made a difference? In my, I don't know, they more comfortable or? No, they just, they make me feel pretty, you know? Okay, well you look pretty.
所以，弗拉尼，枫树，弗拉尼让我迷上了T恤。枫树让我迷上了非常昂贵的网球鞋。对，就是那些。现在我停不下来了。对。有区别吗？在我，我不知道，它们更舒服还是？不，它们只是，它们让我觉得自己挺漂亮的，你知道吗？好吧，那你看起来确实挺漂亮的。
Guys, I wanna get back to the funny guy who's like waiting for us, he's the best. I'm excited for this. He's clearly a patient guy too. Yes, and he makes me laugh, sorry. He's a fellow podcaster and all-around funny guy. At age five, he asked his parents if he could change his name, and they said yes.
伙计们，我想把话题转回那个正等着我们的搞笑艺人身上，他是最棒的。我很期待这个。他显然也是个很有耐心的人。对，而且他让我发笑，抱歉。他也是个播客同行，是个名副其实的搞笑高手。五岁时，他问父母是否可以改名，他们同意了。
I'd consider him part of my own personal SNL Hall of Fame, mastering some of my favorite impressions of all time. And though he's a standalone talent, his comedy work usually comes as a package deal of three. Together, do you know who it is yet? No. Together with his comedy trio, he helped put YouTube on the map
我认为他是我的个人周六夜现场（SNL）名人堂成员，精通我最喜欢的一些有史以来的模仿秀。尽管他是个独当一面的天才，但他的喜剧作品通常是以三人组的形式出现的。总之，你们知道他是谁了吗？不知道。他和他的喜剧三人组一起，
with his hilarious star-studded music videos in the early 2000s. It's my comedy friend, Andy Samberg. Andy Samberg, yep. Andy Samberg! Yes! Andy. Yeah.
凭借20世纪初那些搞笑且大牌云集的音乐录影带，将YouTube推上了地图。他是我的喜剧朋友，安迪·萨姆伯格。安迪·萨姆伯格，没错。安迪·萨姆伯格！太对了！安迪。对。
Woo! God damn, that's so over. This is so relaxed. This is incredibly overdue. I know. How have you, have you been ducking us? Have we not been able to make your deal? What is it?
哇！天呐，这期节目太棒了。这太轻松了。这绝对是早就该有的访谈了。我知道。你最近怎么样，你一直在躲着我们吗？是我们一直约不到你吗？怎么回事？
What's happening? Yeah, Ryder. Uh-huh, got it. Are you at a massage place right now with the screen behind you? Yes. Yeah. Are you getting it?
发生什么事了？对，莱德。嗯哼，明白了。你现在是在按摩店里吗，后面还有个屏幕？对。对。你在做按摩吗？
Are you getting the massage? He said I'm gonna do your podcast but I'm doing one word answer. Yeah. Wait, wait, can I just say that I saw, so Andy knows what I'm about to say, which is I saw him like two weeks ago. Oh really?
你在做按摩吗？他说我要上你们的播客，但我只用一个字回答。等一下，等一下，我能不能说我看到过，所以安迪知道我要说什么，那就是我大概两周前见到他了。哦真的吗？
We were out and he goes, hey, hey idiot, I'm coming to do your stupid podcast. Oh, so you're retelling. This is a major Rashomon. That's pretty true, isn't it? There's almost word for word. You said something like- No, I said hey, first off, hadn't seen you in years.
我们在外面，他走过来说，嘿，嘿，白痴，我要去上你们那破播客了。哦，所以你在复述。这简直是个罗生门。差不多是这样吧，对吧？几乎是一字不差。你说的大概是——不，我说的是，嘿，首先，好几年没见了。
I know. Right? Yeah. Hey, I'm about to be on your very successful podcast. That's literally what I said. And you went, no! You're not supposed to tell me! And stormed off.
我知道。对吧？对。嘿，我马上要上你那个非常成功的播客了。我字面意思是这么说的。然后你去了，不！你不该告诉我！然后气冲冲地走了。
It does sound like this. Going like this, la la la la, holding his ears, la la la la. And I was like, all right, you have a Going like this, la la la la, holding his head, la la la. And I was like, all right, you have a foot on me first off, very intimidating. It does happen quite a bit. And then I spent the rest of the night at the Vanity Fair party, like, sulking
听起来确实是这样。就这样，啦啦啦啦，捂着耳朵，啦啦啦啦。当时我就想，好吧，你占了上风，首先，非常有压迫感。这确实经常发生。然后我在名利场派对剩下的时间里，就像这样，生闷气
because I ruined your night. You were there, I didn't see you there. I was there. I saw you guys all together promoting the show. Sean, you left at 6.45, so. I put some eyes on you there. Andy, we dressed almost exactly the same, although I'm not wearing my hoodie, but baseball hat.
因为我把你的夜晚毁了。你当时在那儿，我没看见你在那儿。我在那儿。我看到你们所有人聚在一起宣传节目。肖恩，你在6点45分就走了，所以。我在那儿看到你了。安迪，我们穿得几乎一模一样，虽然我没穿连帽衫，但都戴着棒球帽。
You can grab it. We got time, right? It's a podcast. It's a great podcast. So Andy, thank you for coming on today. I was really excited about you coming. And I, well, first of all, I didn't know you changed your name. I thought you were always Andy.
你可以拿过来穿。我们有时间，对吧？这是一个播客。这是一个很棒的播客。所以安迪，谢谢你今天能来。我真的很高兴你能来。而且我，首先，我不知道你改过名字。我以为你一直叫安迪。
What was it before? Sean, hi. Nice to see you. Good to see you too. When I was five, I changed my name to Andy from David. My middle name, it was my first name was David and then. And we got it. Your middle name was Annie.
之前叫什么？肖恩，嗨。很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你。我五岁的时候，把名字从大卫改成了安迪。我的中间名，我以前的名字叫大卫，然后。我们懂了。你的中间名是安妮。
I mean my mom was just cool about it is basically the short version of the story. Why do you hate David so much? What's wrong with David? I don't know, I just felt like an Andy is the... Are you serious? I get kind of. I knew you were an Andy.
我是说我妈妈对这件事很酷，这基本上是故事的简短版本。你为什么那么讨厌大卫？大卫怎么了？不知道，我就是觉得安迪是……你是认真的吗？我有点……我知道你是个安迪。
But honestly, like when you look at me, the first name you think personality-wise, obviously is Adam, that's what everyone calls me on accident. But then... Right. Then after that, obviously, is Adam. That's what everyone calls me on accident. But then, then after that, Andy A. McMatches. Adam Sandberg and Justin Bateman. He gets Justin all day.
但老实说，当你看着我时，从性格上讲你首先想到的名字，显然是亚当，每个人都会不小心这么叫我。但接着……对。在那之后，显然就是亚当。每个人都会不小心这么叫我。但接着，在那之后，安迪·A·麦克马切斯。亚当·萨姆伯格和贾斯汀·贝特曼。他整天被人叫贾斯汀。
I got another one yesterday. Do you really? Are you serious? By the way, everyone has someone that they get the name of that person for. And I always think you get big enough and it stops. But then everyone I talk to has someone. No, I'm nowhere near it.
我昨天又碰到了一个。真的吗？你是认真的吗？顺便说一句，每个人都有一个会跟别人名字搞混的人。我一直以为等你名气足够大了，这种事就会停止。但后来我聊过的每个人都有这种情况。不，我还差得远呢。
I get the, I get the, I loved you on SNL, and I'm like, never on it. And then they're like, and I figured like, they've got me confused, and I've talked about with like, either like, Sudeikis me forte, just kind of middle-aged white dude. And they just go, you're- I bet it's forte, cause you're both Wills.
我经常听到的是，我在SNL上特别喜欢你，而我就想，我从来没上过。然后他们就会说，我觉得他们把我搞混了，我讨论过这个问题，要么是苏戴基斯，要么是福特，就那种中年白人。他们就会说，你——我打赌是福特，因为你们俩都叫威尔。
Maybe. You know what, the other day I was in the doctor's office like a couple months ago, and I'm walking out and this guy in the waiting room goes, hey, where are the other two and a half guys? Oh no, you're John Cryer. I'm like, I thought they met Jason and Will, and I got to the elevator and I was like. They thought you were Angus, the kid from doing that.
也许吧。你知道吗，前几个月有一天我在医生办公室，我正往外走，候诊室里有个家伙说，嘿，另外两个半男人在哪儿？哦不，你是乔恩·克赖尔。我就想，我还以为他们说的是杰森和威尔，我走到电梯口时就想。他们以为你是安格斯，那个演节目的孩子。
All grown up. I thought it was gonna be like, Jason and Will, and one of them is notorious for having a massive wang. Yeah, that's it. Old 50 pound unit. Yeah. That's pretty good. That's how long it took me to bring up dicks.
长大了。我还以为会是这样，杰森和威尔，其中一个人以拥有巨大无比的巨根而闻名。对，就是这样。老牌50磅大宝贝。对。我花了好久才把话题引到鸡巴上。
Wait, so let's talk about. I'm all ears. What if you hit a stopwatch as soon as you said it? That's pretty good. That's how long it took me to bring up dicks. Wait, so let's talk about... I'm all ears. What if you hit a stopwatch as soon as you set it? In my defense, I was on ice for a while while you guys chatted about t-shirts and stuff. So I count that time as my preamble time. Hey, can you believe? I mean, this is the kind of talk on a hit podcast. Can I... Wait. can I embarrass myself early?
等等，我们来聊聊。我洗耳恭听。如果你在你一说出口时就按下秒表会怎么样？这挺好的。我花了好久才把话题引到鸡巴上。等等，我们来聊聊……我洗耳恭听。如果你在你刚设定好时就按下秒表会怎么样？恕我直言，你们俩聊T恤什么的那些时候，我一直在那边晾着。所以我把那段时间算作我的开场白时间。嘿，你敢信？我的意思是，这正是一个热门播客里该有的谈话。我能……等一下，我能不能早点让自己出丑？
Andy, you're a fella. I don't know well. We never really crossed paths. I know precisely the, the times we have because, because I've, I think I've always wanted to be your friend and I just never would never cross this path. And you, both these guys know that that's a big deal because I don't really have a lot of friends. But I've targeted you.
安迪，你是个老兄。我跟你不太熟。我们从来没有真正交集过。我确切知道我们有过哪些交集，因为，因为我，我想我一直都想成为你的朋友，只是我们从来没有过交集。这两个家伙都知道这事很大条，因为我其实没多少朋友。但我盯上你了。
And I feel like we'd be great together. I completely agree and I feel the same. This is nice. It's thrilling to have you. Here's the one thing. If you could just quiet down, Will. Sorry, Will, we're talking, dude. Just give us one second.
我觉得我们会成为很好的朋友。我完全同意，我也有同感。这太棒了。你能来太令人兴奋了。有一件事。威尔，如果你能安静点的话。抱歉，威尔，我们在聊天呢，老兄。给我们一秒钟。
Sean, go take a break. I was gonna use your wheels. Yeah. But no Will, we're talking, dude. Just give us one second. Sean, go take a break. Use your wheels. Yeah, but no, I really like the cut of your jib, huh? Likewise and ditto, thank you, first off. All right, I like that you're in Los Angeles. That increases our odds. That's true. I think probably your kids are older than mine,
肖恩，去休息一下吧。我本来想用你的轮子的。对，但是不行，威尔，我们在聊天呢，老兄。给我们一秒钟。肖恩，去休息一下吧。用你的轮子。对，但是不行，我真的很喜欢你的行事风格，哈？彼此彼此，谢谢你，首先。好吧，我喜欢你在洛杉矶。这增加了我们的几率。确实。我想可能你的孩子比我的大，
so that decreases our odds. That's true, although mine can train yours. I pretty much only see people with kids my age at this point. But Jason, you're in luck because we're going to get to know Andy right now. Oh my God, you're right. And we're going to start at the beginning. I don't know, Sean, if you've ever listened to our podcast, but we don't really, we're not known for fucking good questions.
所以这降低了我们的几率。确实如此，不过我的孩子可以训练你的。我现在基本上只见那些孩子跟我差不多大的人。不过杰森，你走运了，因为我们现在就要好好了解安迪了。哦天哪，你说得对。我们要从头开始讲起。肖恩，我不知道你有没有听过我们的播客，但我们其实，我们可不是以提出好问题而闻名的。
We don't like the guest talking much at all. Letting our guest talk a ton. So listen back to your parts. So yeah, so Andy, you take a five. You take a five. That's fine. Can I just say, can I just say, Andy? Yes, what?
我们根本不喜欢嘉宾多说话。而是让嘉宾说个不停。所以回头听听你自己的部分吧。所以，安迪，你休息五分钟。你休息五分钟。没关系。我能不能说，我能不能说，安迪？什么事？
I know you a little bit. Probably better than the other two guys from over the years. Yeah, we've hung out a lot. And we have hung out a lot over the years, and a lot lot, and then Andy was also, first of all, JB, you know this, so that you don't embarrass yourself You know that Andy was in a rest of development Oh what?
我稍微了解你一点。可能比过去这些年的另外两个家伙更了解你。对，我们经常一起玩。我们这些年确实经常一起玩，经常，而且安迪也是，首先，JB，你知道这事的，为了不让自己出丑，你知道安迪演过《发展受阻》吗？哦，什么？
It was a blip Wait blip. How I got I believe it's how I got in the sag We want and we talked about it on the DVD extras of season two as well. That's how long I didn't even know there were DVD extras You were participating in it. Did you know you were in the show? What did I, tell me the name of the show one more time. So it was season two and I had just seen Andy, Andy and Kiva and Yoruba had just done,
这只是个小插曲。等等，小插曲。我是怎么弄到，我相信这就是我加入演员工会（SAG）的方式。我们想要，我们在第二季的DVD花絮里也讨论过这个。我甚至都不知道还有DVD花絮这回事，你当时还参与其中。你知道你当时在节目里吗？我叫什么来着，再告诉我一遍节目的名字。那是第二季，我刚看到安迪、基瓦和约鲁巴，
the Lonely Island Boys as they're known, had just done a pilot called Awesome Town that was produced by Phil Lord and Chris Miller. I wanna see that. Right, Andy? Yes. And it was really good. It was really for Fox. It was a sketch comedy, sort of variety... I don't even know how to describe it.
也就是大家熟知的孤岛三人组（The Lonely Island Boys），刚刚制作了一部名为《美妙小镇》（Awesome Town）的试播集，由菲尔·洛德和克里斯·米勒制作。我想看那个。对吧，安迪？是的。真的很好。那是为福克斯制作的。这是一部素描喜剧，某种形式的综艺……我都不知道该怎么形容。
Special. Before SNL? Yes, pre... Yeah, yeah. The year before. What year was that, Andy, that you guys did that? Do you remember? Like... 2004.
特辑。在 SNL 之前？是的，之前……对，对。前一年。安迪，你们那是哪一年拍的？还记得吗？大概……2004年。
2004. It was so funny. And I was like, oh my God, I was just obsessed with that pilot. These guys are fucking awesome. Yeah, I wanna know about that Andy. So like the lonely, the lonely guy's like. Well hang on, no wait, I wanna know what fucking episode
2004年。太搞笑了。当时我就想，天哪，我简直对那个试播集着迷了。这群家伙太牛逼了。对，我想了解那个时期的安迪。所以就像那个孤岛……等一下，不，我想知道他到底演了《发展受阻》里的哪一集。
he was in in Arrested Development. Where was I? Now don't tell me I was in the scene with him. Andy, go. No. I think it was me and Cross, right Will? Yeah, it was you and Cross. Which, first off, Arrested Development was our favorite show.
我演的哪集？现在别告诉我我和他演了同一场戏。安迪，你说。没有。我觉得是我和克罗斯，对吧，威尔？对，是你和克罗斯。首先，《发展受阻》是我们最喜欢的节目。
Like me, Keev, and Yoram sat around talking about it. It was how it was like, this is the first time ever on American television that comedy has been allowed to move this fast and be this funny and every single person on it destroys. British Office was our inspiration. Or at least me and Will. Which showed, but like, it felt super different. And we were super big fans of Mr. Show also.
就像我和基夫、约鲁巴坐在一起讨论它一样。那是美国电视史上头一次，喜剧被允许以如此快的节奏推进，如此搞笑，里面的每个人都表现炸裂。英国版的《办公室》是我们的灵感来源。或者至少是我和威尔的灵感。虽然看得出来，但感觉完全不一样。我们也是《克罗斯秀》（Mr. Show）的超级大粉丝。
So like the cross-pollination of those things was making our brains explode. So I was not in SAG. Really? I was doing standup and we were shooting our own videos and sort of like trying to cobble it together. And then I got the call to come do this like One line I think I was an usher at blue man group No way, and it was the like next next week on the show thing
所以这两者的交融让我们的脑子都要炸了。所以我当时还不是演员工会的成员。真的吗？我当时在做单口喜剧，我们自己拍视频，勉强把它们拼凑起来。然后我接到电话去演这个，好像就一句台词，我演的是蓝人乐团（Blue Man Group）的引座员。不会吧，那是节目里“下一周看点”的环节。
That's not real right and it was me talking across. I think I had one line Were you in blue man makeup cross? No, no, I don't think I was no I you were like, yeah, you were like in an Usher's outfit or something. Yeah, and my hair was just massive. Seth Meyers said when he first met me, it looked like my hair was trying to eat my head. Man, I gotta, Willie, remember how we used to sit and watch the show, we'd watch them
这不是真的吧？是我和克罗斯对话。我想我只有一句台词。你当时化了蓝人的妆吗，克罗斯？没有，没有，我觉得我没有。你当时穿着引座员的衣服什么的。对，我的头发超级无敌大。塞思·迈耶斯（Seth Meyers）说他第一次见到我时，我的头发看起来就像是要把我的头吃掉一样。天呐，威利，还记得我们以前怎么坐着看那个节目吗，我们看它们
when they were on on Sundays, right? We'd sit there like a couple of newbies, just like, here comes our show, our show's coming on, and we'd watch it, and then we'd sit there like a couple of newbies just like, here comes our show, our show's coming on and we'd watch it and then we'd go outside for smokes during the commercial breaks and then we'd go back in and then we'd check online to see what the comments were and then the next morning what the ratings were. Television without, TV without pity. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
周日播出的时候，对吧？我们就像两个初出茅庐的新人一样坐在那儿，就觉得，我们的节目来了，我们的节目要播了，然后我们看着它，接着我们像两个初出茅庐的新人一样坐在那儿，就觉得，我们的节目来了，我们的节目要播了，然后我们看着它，接着在广告时间去外面抽烟，然后再回去，接着我们上网查看评论，第二天早上再看收视率。不哭泣的电视（TV Without Pity）。对，对，没错。
Like a message board and up at your old house. Yeah, yeah, I do remember that and I remember, you know what, yesterday I was going through some of my stuff upstairs, and I found the New York Times TV Remember they used to put up like this or the New York Times TV guy You know what's coming up in the week and whatever yeah, and Arrested Development was on the cover. It was November of 2003 and they didn't really know what to make it nobody they're like this is Amy who knows and Anyway, I'm just what show you guys. What show are you guys talking about? It's called The Rest of the Moment. Anyway, so Andy comes and does that.
就像留言板一样，在你以前的房子里。对，对，我确实记得那个，我还记得，你知道吗，昨天我在楼上整理一些东西时，我找到了《纽约时报》的电视……还记得他们以前会登出这个或者《纽约时报》的电视专栏，你知道一周内有什么节目之类的，对吧，然后《发展受阻》上了封面。那是2003年11月，他们其实不知道该怎么看待它，没人知道，他们就像是，这是艾米，谁知道呢……总之，我只是……你们在说哪个节目？叫《发展受阻》。总之，安迪就来客串了那个。
And then, so that was like 2004, that was the spring of 2005. Mary Lou Henner on the podcast. Well, crazy, with the dates. Cause it was like one of the last episodes of that second season. So that was like 2005. And then when was it because it was like one of one of the last episodes of that second season So that was like 2005 and then when was it that SN how did it? How did SNL happen you guys had done the pilot that did not get picked up by Fox?
然后，那是2004年左右，那是2005年的春天。玛丽·露·亨纳（Mary Lou Henner）上了播客。哇，真是疯狂，日期对上了。因为那是第二季的最后几集之一。所以那是2005年左右。然后是什么时候因为那是第二季的最后几集之一所以那是2005年左右然后是什么时候因为SNL是怎么发生的你们拍了那个没有被福克斯选中的试播集？
Yes, and then we tried to sell it around town We thought for sure we were gonna get snagged by like MTV 2 or something. Yeah, no dice And we were like we're cooked that was our shot And we were like, we're cooked. That was our shot. And we were writing together splitting a single writing check, working on the MTV Movie Awards for the second year. The three of you? Yeah. Wow.
是的，然后我们到处推销它。我们以为我们肯定会被像 MTV2 之类的频道看中。是的，没戏。我们当时觉得我们完蛋了，那是我们的机会。我们当时觉得我们完蛋了，那是我们的机会。我们当时一起写剧本，平分一份编剧薪水，连续第二年为 MTV 电影大奖工作。你们三个？对。哇。
And the first year we wrote for it, it was Lindsay Lohan. And then the second year we did it, it was Fallon. And so Fallon came in hosting and he brought all the SNL people with him and we just hung out with them basically for three or four straight weeks and loved them and hit it off. And Higgins and Shoemaker were there who were, one is still a big producer there and the other now runs Seth's show,
我们第一年为它写剧本时，主持人是林赛·罗韩。然后我们做的第二年，主持人是法伦。所以法伦来主持，他把所有的 SNL 成员都带来了，我们基本上连续三四周和他们混在一起，超级喜欢他们，一见如故。希金斯（Higgins）和舒梅克（Shoemaker）也在那儿，其中一个人现在还是那里的知名制作人，另一个人现在负责塞思的节目，
but they were high up there. And Jimmy was obviously- Steve Higgins and Mike Shoemaker. The SNL guy. And so we, me, K Yoram, and some others were responsible for writing a few of the like pre-tapes where you put the host in the movies from that year. Right.
但他们在那里地位很高。吉米显然是……史蒂夫·希金斯和迈克·舒梅克。SNL 的人。所以我们，我、基、约鲁巴和其他一些人，负责撰写一些前期录像，就是把主持人放到当年的电影里去的那种。对。
And we wrote a Star Wars one and a Batman one that both got picked. So we were just hanging out with everyone on set, pitching jokes, and they were like, hey, these guys seem like they love comedy a lot. In a way that, you know, you sometimes are shocked to realize that people don't. And did they invite you to audition?
我们写了一个《星球大战》和一个《蝙蝠侠》的短片，两个都被选中了。所以我们当时只是和片场的所有人混在一起，抛出笑话，他们就觉得，嘿，这些家伙看起来非常热爱喜剧。这种热爱，你知道的，有时你会惊讶地发现有些人根本没有。他们邀请你去试镜了吗？
Or did they just say, we've seen enough, let's make them writers? Invited to audition. I had done stand-up at that point for six or seven years, on and off, starting in college. And I'd been on Premium Blend on Comedy Central, which was a thing. And then we had our pilot. I didn't think I knew and I'd been on Premium Blend on Comedy Central, which was a thing. And then we had our pilot.
还是他们直接说，我们看够了，让他们当编剧吧？受邀去试镜。我当时已经断断续续做过六七年单口喜剧了，从大学开始。我上过喜剧中心的《高端混搭》（Premium Blend），那是个挺火的节目。然后我们有了我们的试播集。我当时不知道……我知道我之前在喜剧中心上过《高端混搭》，那是个挺火的节目。然后我们有了我们的试播集。
I didn't think I knew that, that you'd been doing standup before that. Yes. I wouldn't say I was like, H-O-T in the biz, but. Yeah, H-O-T. I was like, I was at the edge of it though. Like I had just gotten to the point where I went in for the meeting at the Improv on Melrose
我不知道这一点，你之前一直在做单口喜剧。是的。我不敢说我当时在行里有多“火”，但……对，火。不过我当时已经处在边缘了。我当时刚谈到那个地步，去梅尔罗斯大道上的即兴喜剧俱乐部（Improv）开会
to be like, hey, you could come start doing real spots. Wow. Just for my sister Tracy, lives in Wisconsin, just a little context. And I didn't know this until I started reading about you that the three, so you started this little comedy troupe which is now also a production company called The Lonely Island.
去争取，嘿，你可以开始来这儿表演真的节目了。哇。只是为了我姐姐特蕾西，她住在威斯康星州，提供一点背景信息。我直到开始读关于你的资料时才知道，这三个人，所以你创立了这个现在也是制作公司的喜剧剧团，叫做“孤岛”（The Lonely Island）。
And it's three of your friends. I did not know this that you met an eighth grade. Yeah, well, Keev and Yoram's seventh grade. That's crazy, seventh grade. And so, and then, so when you got hired on SNL, so you guys had been friends for all those years, and then when you get hired on SNL, they hire all three of you at the same time.
里面有你的三个朋友。我不知道你们是在八年级认识的。对，我和基夫、约鲁巴是七年级认识的。太疯狂了，七年级。所以，然后，当你被 SNL 录用时，你们已经做了那么多年的朋友，然后当你被 SNL 录用时，他们把你们三个人同时录用了。
That's what I couldn't understand, is like, but Andy was on, oh, they were, oh, I see, so they wrote. Did all three of you audition to be performers, or were they just like, we just want to be writers, you can be the performer? I auditioned first, and it went pretty good. And they said, we want you to come back. And then at that time, they asked Keev and Yoram
这就是我一直不理解的地方，就像是，但安迪当时在，哦，原来是这样，所以他们是写剧本的。你们三个人是都去试镜当演员了，还是他们只是说，我们只想找编剧，你可以当演员？我先去试镜的，效果挺不错。他们说，我们希望你再来一次。然后当时，他们问基夫和约鲁巴
if they also wanted to audition. And so Yoram did, and Akiva said, no, I don't want to be on camera. And then the three of us also submitted a writing packet on behalf of the three of us. So we were kind of hedging our bets in all directions. Yeah. Yeah, that's so cool. So Andy's the performer. Yeah. Your mom. Hmm. Your Keef is going to keep them grounded. Tracy, that was like, it's like an idol when the parents bring the kid on and then the parents get on.
他们想不想也去试镜。所以约鲁巴去了，阿基瓦说，不，我不想上镜。然后我们三个人还代表我们三个提交了一份剧本。所以我们在各个方向都给自己买了个保险。对。对，太酷了。所以安迪是演员。对。你妈妈。唔。你的基夫会让他们脚踏实地。特蕾西，这就好比，就像父母带孩子来，然后父母自己也上镜的那种偶像剧。
So then at what point then do you guys say, hey, you know, we make some pretty snazzy vids too. Do you guys wanna maybe hire us for that? We weren't hired for that, interestingly. We had been doing it. Like we'd even made a few joke raps. Thank you very much. The best.
那么你们是什么时候说，嘿，你知道吗，我们也拍一些非常时髦的视频。你们要不要考虑雇我们拍那个？有趣的是，我们不是为此被雇佣的。我们一直都在做这个。甚至我们还拍了几首搞笑说唱。非常感谢。太绝了。
It just killed me. And you basically started the S&L Digital Shorts. They'd never done anything like that. Now they do it all the time. Well, McKay had done it. McKay, yeah. Oh, McKay did it. That's right.
这简直笑死我了。而且你基本上开创了 SNL 数字短片（Digital Shorts）的先河。他们以前从没做过那种东西。现在他们经常这么做。不过麦凯（McKay）做过。麦凯，对。哦，麦凯做过。没错。
That's right. Forgive me. And Smigel? Much less frequently. But his were great, obviously. TV Funhouse and all that. Yeah. McKay did them with like Pat, what's his name, and a bunch of those dudes.
没错。原谅我。还有斯米格尔（Smigel）？频率没那么高。但他的显然也很棒。电视趣味屋（TV Funhouse）那些的。对，麦凯和帕特（Pat，不知道姓啥）还有那帮家伙一起做过。
I forget that guy's name. Anyway, but yes, but those guys had done them, but they were more esoteric, if you will. Like they were kind of off the wall and kind of, you guys kind of were able to hone in on stuff. Obviously McKay's a legend, so I'm not disparaging him. And anyway, the guy's an absolute giant. But you guys came in, we're doing something different, and you really...
我忘了那家伙叫什么名字了。总之，是的，那些家伙做过，但它们更深奥一点，如果你这么觉得的话。就有点稀奇古怪的，而你们则能够聚焦于某些东西。很显然麦凯是个传奇，所以我不是在贬低他。总之，那家伙是个绝对巨擘。但你们来了之后，做了一些不同的事情，而且你们真的……
I remember that night that... that Lazy Sunday came out. I think it was the last show before Christmas, am I right? Yeah, Christmas show, our first season. Yeah, I know it. It's insane. I'd like to see you maybe just have a bit of a weed problem in the future, just to knock down your memory a little bit.
我记得那天晚上……《懒散星期天》（Lazy Sunday）播出了。我没记错的话，那是圣诞节前的最后一期节目吧？对，圣诞节那一期，我们的第一季。我知道。太疯狂了。我希望你以后能有点大麻问题，好让你的记忆力稍微下降一点。
Yeah. But I remember even just the reaction in the building, Andy, and you, to walk us through that, because it was palpable. That thing, they aired that thing, and it was just like electricity. Everybody went like, there was pre-Lazy Sunday, and there was post-Lazy Sunday.
对。但我甚至还记得大楼里的反应，安迪，你带我们回顾一下当时的情景，因为那真的是能切实感受到的。那东西，他们把那东西播出来的一瞬间，简直就像触电一样。所有人都觉得，那之前是《懒散星期天》之前，之后是《懒散星期天》之后。
I'm serious. But tell people what Lazy Sunday is. Yeah, yeah. Lazy Sunday was our first hashtag comedy rap that we aired on the show. Right. It was me and Parnell, the great Chris Parnell. Chris Parnell. Who everyone on Earth loves.
我是认真的。不过给观众们讲讲什么是《懒散星期天》。对，对。《懒散星期天》是我们在节目中播出的第一首话题喜剧说唱。对。我和 Parnell，伟大的 Chris Parnell 一起拍的。Chris Parnell。全世界每个人都爱他。
The greatest, nicest guy in the world. And, you know, we had done, like I said, we had done stuff on our own like that for like, thelonelyisland.com. And like, tried to get it put on other websites that had bandwidth for streaming before YouTube existed. But you guys emerged at the same time YouTube was created, which was phenomenal. Yeah, and it was very fortuitous for us
世界上最伟大、最nice的人。而且，你知道的，正如我所说，我们之前在 thelonelyisland.com 上自己做过类似的东西。并且试图把它放到其他在 YouTube 诞生之前就有流媒体带宽的网站上。但你们出现的时间正好赶上了 YouTube 的创立，这太惊人了。对，这对我们来说非常幸运，
where it was like, oh, YouTube became a thing at the moment we had this song people wanted to share. Yeah. And we will be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So guys, if you're anything like me, you've caught yourself at some point in your life
就好像，哦，在我们正好有这首人们想要分享的歌曲的时候，YouTube 诞生了。我们马上回来。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。所以伙计们，如果你们有跟我类似经历的话，你们肯定在人生某个阶段发现过自己在
comparing your life to other people, which is really, really unhealthy. And social media plays a huge part of that. You know, this quote I've always loved by Theodore Roosevelt, like by the way, I can't believe I'm quoting Theodore Roosevelt, but comparison is the thief of joy. And so it's really easy to get caught up in today's society with social media and everything going on to go,
拿自己的人生跟别人做比较，这真的、真的非常不健康。而社交媒体在这其中扮演了巨大的角色。你知道的，我一直很喜欢西奥多·罗斯福（Theodore Roosevelt）的一句名言，顺便说一句，我简直不敢相信自己在引用西奥多·罗斯福的话，但“比较是快乐的小偷”。所以在当今充满社交媒体和各种纷扰的社会里，人们很容易陷入这种想法：
why don't I look like that? Why don't I have that? Why don't I do this? And I've caught myself doing that throughout the years and it's really unhealthy. It's not a good thing and it needs to be addressed in your own life. And so that's what I do.
为什么我长得不像那样？为什么我没有那个？为什么我做不到这个？我发现自己这些年来一直在这么做，这真的很不健康。这不是件好事，你需要在你自己的生活中去解决它。这就是我正在做的。
I go to therapy and I talk about stuff if that particular issue comes up about comparing. Because comparing yourself to others, total joy killer. It's so easy to look at someone's social media and think they've got it all figured out. But the truth is everyone's got their own stuff going on behind the scenes that you can't see, right? So therapy can help you focus on what you want
我会去看心理医生，如果出现关于比较的特定问题，我就会去谈论它。因为拿自己跟别人比较，绝对是个快乐终结者。看着别人的社交媒体，很容易让人觉得他们把一切都搞定了。但事实是，每个人在你看不到的幕后都有他们自己的烦恼，对吧？所以心理治疗可以帮助你专注于你想要的东西，
instead of what others have, so you can start living your best life. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist
而不是别人拥有什么，这样你才能开始过上最好的生活。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与持证心理治疗师匹配，
and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Stop comparing and start focusing with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartList today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. SmartList gets support from ZipRecruiter. Summertime's here and all those seasonal gigs are opening up, you know, stuff like Mule Wrangling and running those drama camps. The thing is, there's a real need for people
并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。停止比较，开始专注，就用 BetterHelp。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com/SmartList，首月即可享受 9 折优惠。网址是 BetterHelpHELP.com/SmartList。SmartList 得到了 ZipRecruiter 的支持。夏天到了，所有那些季节性的零工都开始招人了，你知道的，比如骡马驯养员和戏剧营管理员。问题是，社会上真的很需要具备
with those specific skills, but they can be kind of hard to come by, you know? Whether you're hiring for one of those roles or any other role, how do you find top talent before the competition gets to them? ZipRecruiter. And right now you can try ZipRecruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist.
这些特定技能的人，但他们可能有点难找，对吧？无论你是在招聘这些职位还是其他任何职位，如何在竞争对手之前找到顶级人才？ZipRecruiter。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartlist 免费试用 ZipRecruiter。
ZipRecruiter's got this powerful matching technology that really digs in to find you top-notch talent for roles you're looking to fill. As soon as you post your job, ZipRecruiter's smart technology shows you the qualified peeps that are a perfect fit. Gear up for summer with ZipRecruiter's high-speed hiring tools. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try ZipRecruiter for free.
ZipRecruiter 拥有强大的匹配技术，能够深入挖掘，为你寻找你想要填补的职位的顶尖人才。你一发布工作，ZipRecruiter 的智能技术就会向你展示完美契合的合格人才。用 ZipRecruiter 的高速招聘工具为夏天做好准备。来看看为什么五分之四在 ZipRecruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主能在第一天内就招到优质候选人。现在就访问这个专属网址免费试用 ZipRecruiter。
ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. We get support from State Farm. For the love of Pete! Something you might say when your car gets damaged. But that won't get you the help you need for your car. Screaming out to Pete?
ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再说一遍，网址是 ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。我们得到了 State Farm 的支持。看在皮特的份上！这可能是你车子受损时说的话。但这并不能为你提供车子所需的帮助。对着皮特大喊大叫？
That's not going to do anything. What you should really say is something that can actually help. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. For help, filing your claim 24-7. When things get complicated and you need ways to get help, State Farm gives you options there too. Maybe you like to handle things in person or on the phone with your local agent. Or you prefer to do it on statefarm.com or their award-winning app.
那可什么用都没有。你真正该说的是能真正帮上忙的话。比如好邻居，State Farm 一直都在。全天候为你提供理赔帮助。当事情变得复杂，你需要寻求帮助的途径时，State Farm 也能为你提供多种选择。也许你喜欢当面处理，或者通过电话与当地代理人沟通。或者你更喜欢在 statefarm.com 或他们屡获殊荣的应用程序上操作。
State Farm lets you do things your way. With a State Farm agent, you know someone is there to help protect your future by helping you choose the coverage you need. With so many coverage options, it feels good knowing you can find what fits for you. Whether it's on the phone, online, or on the award-winning State Farm mobile app, however you choose, like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. [♪ music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music You wrote it, or you submitted it on a Wednesday, just at the table read? How did you, did you go to Shoemaker and those guys?
State Farm 让你随心所欲。通过 State Farm 代理人，你知道有人随时准备通过帮你选择所需的险种来保护你的未来。拥有如此多的险种选择，知道你能找到适合自己的选项，这种感觉真好。无论是通过电话、在线还是通过屡获殊荣的 State Farm 移动应用，无论你选择哪种方式，正如好邻居一般，State Farm 一直都在。你是把它写下来了，还是在周三提交的，就在围读剧本的时候？你是怎么做的，你去找肖梅克（Shoemaker）和他们那些人了吗？
Like how did that come about? Keev and Yoram had done one on their own, which was an idea we'd had for a while. I left town to do some general meetings. Yeah, sure, sure. The best part of our business. You had a kingdom to fill. And how are you?
就像那是怎么开始的？基夫（Keev）和约拉姆（Yoram）自己做过一个，那是我们一直都有的一个想法。我离开镇上开一些常规会议。没错，当然，当然。我们这个行业最棒的部分。你有一个王国需要去填满。你好吗？
How are you? I don't know why I'm here. What would you like to do next, Mr. The best part of our business. You had a kingdom. And how are you? How are you? I don't know why I'm here. What would you like to do next, Mr. Samberg? I mean, obviously we're familiar with your work. Sure. Not gonna say any of it because we're not. Right? For Tracy, that's how all those general meetings in Hollywood go.
你好吗？我不知道我为什么会在这里。萨姆伯格（Samberg）先生，你接下来想做什么？我的意思是，显然我们对你的作品很熟悉。当然。什么都不打算说，因为我们不是。对吧？对于特雷西（Tracy）来说，好莱坞的所有那些常规会议都是这样的。
Well, you leave everyone thinking like, I'm about to make 12 movies in a row and then you never Anyways they made a little music video thing called Bing Bong Brothers Which was a send-up of this song by the yin-yang twins and we showed it to Shoemaker and Higgins and they were like This is great. But we have so much cast right now our first season I think we had like 17 or 18 cast members Wow, and they were like if you can do stuff like this, but put the cast in it, right? but we have so much cast right now. Our first season I think we had like 17 or 18 cast members. Wow. And they were like, if you can do stuff like this but put the cast in it,
好吧，你会让每个人都觉得，我马上要连拍 12 部电影了，然后你永远——总之，他们做了一个叫《乒乓兄弟》（Bing Bong Brothers）的小音乐视频，是对阴阳双煞（Yin Yang Twins）这首歌的恶搞，我们把它拿给肖梅克和希金斯（Higgins）看，他们觉得：“这太棒了。但我们现在的演员阵容太庞大了，第一季我想我们大概有 17 或 18 个演员阵容。”哇，他们说：“如果你能做出这样的东西，但把演员放进去，对吧？但我们现在的演员阵容太庞大了。第一季我想我们大概有 17 或 18 个演员阵容。哇。而他们说，如果你能做出这样的东西，但把演员放进去，
you don't even have to ask our permission, just go shoot something and if it's good, then we can try and use it at dress to change sets. Because we always need pre-tape pieces to change over sets during commercial breaks and stuff is not enough always. And it can save other people's live sketches if you have a pre-tape. Right.
你甚至不需要征求我们的同意，直接去拍点什么，如果效果好，我们就可以在换布景的排练时试着使用它。因为我们总是需要预录片段来在商业广告插播等期间更换布景，而且往往不够。如果你有一个预录片段，它还可以拯救其他人的直播小品。没错。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right, right. That was kind of honestly why they were pushing us to do it. And so then we did one that was based on an idea Forte had had called Lettuce, where it's just me and him dramatically having a conversation and taking huge bites out of heads of lettuce on the stoop. And that was the first one that aired.
对，对，对。对，对。老实说，这正是他们当时敦促我们这样做的原因。所以后来我们根据福特（Forte）的一个名为《生菜》（Lettuce）的想法做了一个，内容就是我和他戏剧性地进行对话，并在门廊上狠狠地咬下大头生菜。那是第一个播出的。
Yes. That's so good. Just the most forte shit ever. I forgot about that. I'm just gonna be so serious. Yeah, that's his entire life. And then we did another one that was basically that one again, called Peyote, that didn't air until the end of that season. And then the third one we that was basically that one again Called peyote that didn't air till the end of that season and then the third one we shot was lazy Sunday, which was a
是的。太棒了。简直就是最具福特风格的破事。我都忘了。我只想表现得那么严肃。是的，这就是他的整个人生。然后我们做了另一个，基本上又是那个风格，叫《佩奥特碱》（Peyote），直到那一季结束才播出。然后我们拍的第三个是《懒惰的星期天》（Lazy Sunday），这是一个
Dork rap about me and Parnell having a lazy Sunday going to see the Chronicles of Narnia So good how big can I but I mean this sounds such a cheesy fan question because I am and we are, but like, it's so dumb, so just bear with me, and I'm sure you've been asked this a million times. How did you- Is show business hard? It's so hard. No, is, you know, dick in the box.
书呆子说唱，讲我和帕内尔（Parnell）过了一个懒惰的星期天，去看《纳尼亚传奇》（The Chronicles of Narnia）。太棒了，我怎么能——但这听起来像是一个很俗气的粉丝问题，因为我确实是，我们也是，但这就很蠢，所以请忍耐一下，我确信你已经被问过一百万次了。你怎么——演艺界很难吗？太难了。不，是，你知道的，盒中蛋蛋。
Like all of them became so huge on their own. How did you, I would ask the same question to a musician. How did you come up with them? Is it like, are you at home in the shower thinking of the most bizarre, funny shit? Or is it like, do you come up with a song first and then you're like, let's do a video? Or like, how does it all happen?
就像它们所有作品一样，各自变得如此巨大。你究竟是——我也会向音乐家问同样的问题。你是怎么想出这些点子的？是不是就像，你是在家里洗澡时想着那些最离奇、最搞笑的破事？还是说，你是先想出一首歌，然后才说“我们拍个视频吧”？或者说，这一切是怎么发生的？
It's different every time. So like, Lazy Sunday was very similar to a song Keev and Yoram had done before we were on SNL called The Heist, which was about them talking about chamomile tea and stuff. So it was totally very like, this is our version of that, which now we feel slightly guilty about
每次都不一样。所以，像《懒惰的星期天》非常类似于基夫和约拉姆在我们加入 SNL 之前做过的一首歌，叫《抢劫》（The Heist），那是关于他们讨论洋甘菊茶之类的事情的。所以这完全非常像是，这是我们对那个作品的版本，现在我们对此感到有点小小的内疚，
because everyone and their mom has done that and still some are doing it. And feels a little like, okay, we get it. And then like Dick in a Box was Timberlake hosted and was like, we were chatting with him in our office and sort of realized we all had come up on the same music in the early 90s, like that early 90s R&B and that we loved that style.
因为每个人和他们的妈妈都做过那个，而且现在还有人正在做。并且感觉有点像是，“好吧，我们懂了。”然后就像《盒中蛋蛋》是汀布莱克（Timberlake）主持的，当时我们在办公室和他聊天，然后突然意识到我们都是在 90 年代初听着相同的音乐长大的，比如那种 90 年代初的 R&B，并且我们都热爱这种风格。
And he was obviously capable of singing it really, really well. The little half glasses, the little Barry Gibb glasses are just... Yeah, exactly. Sorry, keep going. Which, you know, I look back at it now, I'm like, oh, this is like almost fully back in style. Yeah.
而且他显然有能力把这首歌唱得非常非常棒。那个小半框眼镜，那个小巴里·吉布（Barry Gibb）眼镜简直是——是的，完全正确。抱歉，你继续。现在回想起来，我心想，哦，这简直完全回归时尚了。是的。
But Andy, so, but I kind of want to get back into, because there was that, like I said before, there was that moment, sort of pre and post Lazy Sunday. And I just remember as soon as that hits and it goes crazy, like one of the first sort of viral videos, if you will, really, all of a sudden, it's like you guys are at Paramount, right? All of a sudden, you're at Brad Gray's office, you're making Hot Rod, and you've got a movie deal, and you've got all that. Like, it just went like that.
但是安迪，所以，我还是想回到那个话题，因为正如我之前所说，有过那样一个时刻，可以说是《懒惰的星期天》之前和之后的时刻。我只记得一旦那个视频火了并疯狂传播开来，就像是最早的病毒视频之一，如果你愿意这么称呼的话，突然之间，你们就去了派拉蒙，对吧？突然之间，你在布拉德·格雷（Brad Gray）的办公室里，你们在制作《热血高手》（Hot Rod），你们有了一份电影合约，拥有了这一切。就像，事情就这样发生了。
Yes. Right? Am I right about that? Some would argue too fast. Really? No. Yeah. Not me. I mean, Hot Rod, you know all about because you're in it, and you're fantastic in it, and we were so grateful you did it. Yes.
是的。对吧？我说的对吗？有些人甚至会辩称发生得太快了。真的吗？没有。是的。只有我没有。我是说，《热血高手》你很清楚，因为你在里面演了，而且你在里面表现得棒极了，我们非常感激你参演了。是的。
No. Yes. I actually do remember, you know what? I do remember, Andy, funny you say it too fast, I remember one day going to Paramount to meet Lorne one of the off weeks, and you guys were at the Broadway video office, do you remember that? You guys were writing?
不。是的。我实际上确实记得，你知道吗？我确实记得，安迪，你开玩笑说它太快了，我记得有一天去派拉蒙见洛恩（Lorne），那是某一个休息周，你们当时在百老汇视频办公室，你还记得吗？你们当时在写剧本？
Rewriting it, yeah. And you were rewriting it. And I remember that you, Keith, and you were being in the room. And I was like, how's it going? You guys have your laptops. And you were so, you guys were so stressed out. You're like, I don't know if we're gonna be able to do this.
在重写，是的。你们在重写。我记得你、基夫，你们当时在房间里。我就问：“进展怎么样？”你们拿着笔记本电脑。你们当时太——你们压力太大了。你们说：“我不知道我们能不能做到这一点。”
Because it was like really quick. And they're like, great, here's a movie, rewrite it and we start shooting July 1st. Yeah. I mean, we were psyched, and we knew that it was a window that had opened and you gotta go through it, but it was also like... I mean, I had been on someone's desk
因为这真的非常快。他们说：“太好了，这是一部电影，重写它，我们 7 月 1 日开拍。”是的。我是说，我们很兴奋，我们知道这是一扇已经打开的窗户，你必须穿过去，但这也像是……我是说，在那之前大约一年半，
like a year and a half before that, dreaming of this happening, and then all of a sudden it's like, boom! And it's happening so fast. This is the thing I've really thought about more as we've gotten older is It never occurred to me how anyone else was perceiving us because we were so in it and like shot out of a cannon And now I'm like oh
我曾坐在某个人的办公桌前，梦想着这种事发生，然后突然之间，就像是：轰！事情发生得太快了。随着我们年龄渐长，我真正开始思考的一点是， 我从来没想过别人是如何看待我们的，因为我们太投入了，就像是从大炮里发射出去一样。现在我想：哦，
If that happened to someone now, I'd be like who the fuck are these guys? What did they do to get this? One song thing? Exactly. Exactly. Your proof of concept though was already just like right there and you'd already been stamped and embraced by the SNL pedigree and embraced by the exact demo, Paramount's asking you guys to hit.
如果这种事现在发生在别人身上，我肯定会想：这群混蛋是谁？他们做了什么才得到这个？就凭一首歌？没错。没错。不过，你们的概念验证已经就在那里了，而且你们已经有了 SNL 出身背景的盖章和认可，并得到了派拉蒙希望你们触及的目标受众的拥抱。
So it was like, I'm sure you guys had, you weren't paralyzed with fear, but sort of knowing you're going into new ground. Yes, also we were still like, not just actually young, but like young in the industry. So for us, we still had the like, no man, we're gonna make it this. And like, no shade, because I love this movie.
所以这就像是，我确信你们——你们并没有被恐惧吓瘫，而是多少知道自己正在涉足新的领域。是的，而且我们当时依然——不仅仅是实际上很年轻，而且在行业里也很年轻。所以对我们来说，我们依然抱着这种心态：“不，老兄，我们要把这个做好。”而且，绝无贬低之意，因为我超爱这部电影，
They wanted Dodgeball, and we wanted like, Wet Hot American Summer. And I think Hot Rod ended up somewhere in between. Had Akiva and Norma directed anything other than the digital shorts at that point? No. Right. But you know, we had shot,
他们想要《疯狂躲避球》（Dodgeball），而我们想要像《夏日美国湿热高飞》（Wet Hot American Summer）那样的东西。我想《热血高手》最终落在了两者之间。在那之前，阿基瓦（Akiva）和诺马（Norma）除了数码短片还导演过别的吗？没有。没错。但你知道，我们拍过，
Kiva directed basically everything we had done for five straight years leading up to that. Like we moved to LA together and just started shooting stuff because we both went to film school. And that was the plan. Like we're just gonna keep shooting stuff and show people why we're funny and not try to tell them. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
在长达五年的时间里，基夫几乎导演了我们在此之前所做的一切。就像我们一起搬到洛杉矶，然后就开始拍东西，因为我们都上过电影学校。这就是计划。就像我们只要一直拍东西，向人们展示我们为什么有趣，而不是试图去告诉他们。是的，是的，是的。
It's funny, I was talking about photos just before about finding the arrested thing. I was also found, I have a photo weirdly in a silver, it looks like a really fancy frame, and it's on the set of Hot Rod. I just saw it, and it's Keev talking to me in this, and he's being really serious, and I'm being really serious, and I'm like, we're on the set of Hot Rod. I just saw it, and it's Keev talking to me in this, and he's being really serious, and I'm being really serious, and I'm like, we're on the set of Hot Rod, right?
真搞笑，我刚才还在谈论照片，关于找到那个被捕的东西。我还发现了一张照片，很奇怪地放在一个银色里，看起来像是一个非常精致的相框，那是《热血高手》片场的照片。我刚刚看到它，那是基夫在里面跟我说话，他表现得非常严肃，我也表现得非常严肃，然后我想：我们在《热血高手》的片场，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Like, it couldn't be more serious. He's like, say babe three more times. Yeah, exactly. Andy, where does the film school and filmmaking kind of desire for you live currently? Or is it just sort of just acting now, or do you still kind of thirst for making stuff?
对，对，对，对。就像，不能再严肃了。他说：“再多说三遍宝贝。”是的，完全正确。安迪，电影学校和电影制作的这种愿望目前对你来说处于什么状态？还是说现在基本上只是演戏，或者你依然对创作充满渴望？
Well, I mean, I'm basically a producer on almost everything I do. And I feel like I'm a creative producer, if that's a thing. For sure. And it's not for everyone. Andy, explain for Tracy what the difference is. Like a hardcore producer-producer is the person who's actually talking to all the production heads
嗯，我的意思是，我基本上是我所做几乎所有事情的制片人。我觉得我是一个富有创造力的制片人，如果这种说法存在的话。当然。这并不适合所有人。安迪，请为特雷西解释一下两者的区别。一个硬核的制片人-制片人是那个真正与所有制作负责人交谈、
and putting together a movie or a show and dealing with the studio or network on a daily basis. And it's a grind and it's a specific skill set and it's a specific personality type that is really valuable and rare to find someone that's great at it. And then for me, I'm like, I am heavily involved in the creative decisions
组建电影或节目，并日常与工作室或电视网打交道的人。这是一项苦差事，需要特定的技能组合，也需要特定的个性类型，能找到一个擅长此道的人非常珍贵且罕见。然后对我来说，我是：我深度参与了我所参与的所有事情的创意决策中，
of everything I'm in basically, if whoever I'm working with is amenable. But like, that to me is, that was my role with the guys, with Keev and Yoram, so that's kinda how I developed. You were on the producing track as opposed to the directing track in film school, yeah? I mean, I was technically directing, but I didn't enjoy it because it's just so much multitasking
基本上只要和我合作的人能够听取意见。但对我来说，那曾是我和这群伙伴、基夫和约拉姆在一起时的角色，所以这就是我成长的方式。你在电影学校走的是制片路线，而不是导演路线，对吧？我的意思是，我技术上是在导演，但我并不喜欢它，因为有太多的多任务处理，
and I also wanted to be acting in stuff. I mean, I don't know, I am blown away by people like yourself that can act in it while directing. That to me is such a head fuck. I don't know how to do that. Just try it once, you'll see, oh, it's pretty efficient. It's a... Well, let me ask you this, not to get too granular,
而且我也想在里面演戏。我是说，我不知道，我对像你这样能在导演的同时还能在里面演戏的人佩服得五体投地。对我来说，这太烧脑了。我不知道该怎么做到这一点。只要尝试一次，你就会发现：哦，这其实挺高效的。这是一个……好吧，让我问你这个，话虽不要说得太细枝末节，
but the one thing that worries me more than anything is giving notes to the actors I'm in a scene with. Like, I have this insecurity as soon as I'm like, can you do it more like this? And they're like, fuck you, bitch. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, you do it more. You do it more like this.
但我最担心的一件事，莫过于给我所在的场景中的演员提意见。比如，当我刚要说“你能演得更像这样一点吗”的时候，我心里就有一种不安全感，而他们则会说：“去你的，婊子。”是的，完全正确。是的，你来演得更像。你来演得更像这样。
I know what it's gonna be. It is true. It is a certain amount of unstated arrogance and hubris to actually be giving a note to somebody you're on an equal play field with. I hear you on that for sure. I have no explanation for that aside from the kindness of the person that's listening to the note. Especially like what if you're doing like romance stuff? Right. Yeah.
我知道会是怎样。这确实是真的。对一个与你处于同等地位的人提出意见，本身就带有一种未明言的傲慢与自大。关于这一点我完全听懂了。除了听意见的人心怀善意之外，我对这一点毫无解释。特别是像——如果你在拍浪漫戏之类的呢？对。是的。
I feel like I wasn't believing that you like me enough. Right. Be more into it. Yeah. And that's how you met your wife, right? Be more into it. Okay, on this tick, marry me. Right. I want to feel from your kiss that we should be married. Here we go. Still rolling. Rick, you're just like face to face and they're like sitting there and you keep going, no, more. No, I don't buy it. Again, no, close deeper.
我觉得我当时并不相信你足够喜欢我。对。再投入一点。是的。这就是你认识你太太的方式，对吧？再投入一点。好吧，在这个勾选上，嫁给我。对。我想从你的吻中感受到我们应该结婚。我们开始吧。还在拍。里克，你们就是面对面，然后他们就坐在那里，你一直说：“不，再多一点。不，我不买账。再来，不，贴得更深。”
But you do, but yeah, but you do, because TV is sort of a writer's medium, you do end up by default kind of directing, especially in comedy, kind of directing anyway, right? And so it's pretty, it's directing adjacent. Yes, we did eight seasons of Brooklyn Nine-Nine, for example, and I was a producer on that. And as the show went on, I would definitely be on set
但你会的，但是——是的，但你会的，因为电视剧在某种程度上是编剧的媒介，你最终还是会默认进行导演，尤其是在喜剧中，无论如何都会进行某种程度的导演，对吧？所以这可以说是与导演相邻的领域。是的，举个例子，我们拍了八季的《神烦警探》（Brooklyn Nine-Nine），我是那部剧的制片人。随着剧集的推进，我绝对会作为制片人留在片场，
as a producer, not just an actor, a lot creatively. And making sure scenes were working and being a big part of editing with Dan Gore and knowing like we're gonna need like some alts on the end of this scene because this isn't playing. You can just feel it in the room. It's not landing right. And then you pow wow and you pitch a couple extra jokes
作为一名制作人而不仅仅是一名演员，在创意上有很多收获。要确保场景能够发挥作用，与丹·戈尔一起深度参与剪辑，并意识到我们在这个场景的结尾需要一些备用镜头，因为当前的效果不太对。你在现场就能感觉到它没有产生预期的效果。然后你们开个小会，提出几个额外的笑话。
and then you have each cast member try a different thing and then you know you have options and blah, blah, blah. And you're hiring the directors. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you worked with the great Dan Gore and obviously you had a lot of great comedic minds on that show as well with the great Mike Schur,
接着让每个演员尝试不同的表现方式，然后你就知道自己有备选方案了，诸如此类。而且你在雇佣导演。对。是的。是的，你和伟大的丹·戈尔合作过，显然该剧还有很多其他伟大的喜剧大脑，比如伟大的迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur），
who we all adore, and Phil and Chris as well. Yeah, they shot the pilot. They shot the pilot. So you had a pretty, that was like a fucking hall of Fame team. I got to rewatch it during the pandemic with my oldest unarchie. He was there and able to super into it. We ended up watching it all through.
我们所有人都非常崇拜他，还有菲尔（Phil）和克里斯（Chris）。是的，他们拍了试播集。他们拍了试播集。所以你们拥有了一个，那简直就像是一个名人堂级别的团队。在大流行期间，我和我的大儿子阿尔奇（Archie）一起重温了这部剧。他在那里，并且能够超级投入。我们最终把它从头到尾看完了。
So, so, so funny. And, you know, one of the through lines we mentioned right at the top, one of the through lines in what you do so well, and you do so many things so well, but you always... There's oftentimes you incorporate music into what you do. And I kind of wanted to understand a little bit about like what your history is with music. Did you study music as a kid?
太好笑了。而且，你知道，我们刚才在一开始提到的一条主线，你所做的事情中的主线之一，你把许多事情都做得很好，但你总是……很多时候你会在你的作品中融入音乐。我有点想了解一下你与音乐的历史。你小时候学过音乐吗？
First of all, you got a great voice, you got great timing. Um... it's true. So, how do you come by it? Um, well, thanks. I grew up in a house that music was always playing and me and one of my two sisters were both kind of just always obsessed with music. I don't know exactly why.
首先，你有一副好嗓子，你的节奏感也很好。嗯……这是真的。所以，你是怎么掌握这一点的？嗯，谢谢。我在一个音乐总是播放的家里长大，我和我的两个姐姐之一都总是对音乐着迷。我不知道具体为什么。
I think I had a father who had a great appreciation of it, had a big record collection. And then when I hit junior high and high school, I pretty much just went to the record store all the time. I grew up in Berkeley, California, where the first Amiga music was built. And I was at Amiga Records in high school two or three times a week, just DITC,
我想我的父亲对音乐有很高的欣赏力，他有很多唱片收藏。然后当我上初中和高中时，我几乎总是去唱片店。我在加州伯克利长大，第一家阿米巴音乐（Amoeba Music）就是在那建立的。我在高中的时候，每周去阿米巴唱片店（Amoeba Records）两三次，就在挖唱片（DITC），
which is digging through the gates. They do vinyl again, right? They sell, they're still in business, they sell vinyl. Yeah, apparently vinyl has made a massive resurgence. Yeah. Massive. They do vinyl again, right? Mm-hmm. They sell, they're still in business, they sell vinyl. Yeah, apparently vinyl has made a massive resurgence. Yeah. Massive. Yeah, it's cool. Wait, so I wanna talk more about that.
也就是翻唱那些门道。他们现在又出黑胶唱片了，对吧？他们在卖，他们还在营业，在卖黑胶。对，显然黑胶唱片卷土重来了。对，太火了。他们又出黑胶唱片了，对吧？嗯哼。他们在卖，他们还在营业，在卖黑胶。对，显然黑胶唱片卷土重来了。对，太火了。对，挺酷的。等等，所以我想多聊聊这个。
So you grew up in the Bay Area, you grew up around music, what kind of music did your dad listen to and then you listened to, and what kind of would you, did you gravitate towards a specific genre out of Miba Records? Ah, yeah.
所以你在湾区长大，从小接触音乐，你爸爸听的是什么音乐，然后你听的是什么，在米巴唱片公司出品的音乐里，你会倾向于某种特定的流派吗？啊，对。
Take those in order, please You can go backwards it was definitely all kinds of music I mean I think a lot of people that grew up in the Bay Area would say the same thing which is music is just a big part of the culture there for no matter who you are as a kid there and so like there were definitely people who were like we're punks and we listen to punk and like we're backpackers and we listen to hip
请按顺序回答，你可以倒着来。那绝对是各种各样的音乐。我的意思是，很多在湾区长大的人都会这么说，那就是音乐在那里是一种很大的文化的一部分，无论你小时候是个什么样的人。所以，肯定有人会说，我们是朋克，我们听朋克，还有人说我们是背包客，我们听嘻
hop. But most people were like, I listen to 12 genres of music and I love the right right right of all of them. And we were certainly that and my friend group was that where we'd be like super into dancehall and reggae but also super into contemporary hip hop and old hip hop and old funk soul because of hip hop because we chased down the samples from our favorite hip hop songs. But also I love Bob Dylan and grew up listening to Bob Dylan and wore my mom's purple scarf
哈。但大多数人会说，我听12种流派的音乐，而且每一种我都非常非常喜欢。我们当然也是这样，我的朋友圈子也是这样，我们会超级喜欢舞厅舞曲和雷鬼，但也超级喜欢当代嘻哈、老派嘻哈，以及因为嘻哈而喜欢的老派放克和灵魂乐，因为我们去追溯我们最喜欢的嘻哈歌曲里的采样。但我也喜欢鲍勃·迪伦，从小听着鲍勃·迪伦的歌长大，高中时还戴着我妈的紫色围巾，
to try and look like Bob Dylan in high school. That's great. But you were so adept at hip hop and you guys were kind of like the West Coast comedy Beastie Boys. Well that's high praise. Yeah, oh nice Will. It's true.
试图让自己看起来像鲍勃·迪伦。太棒了。但你对嘻哈音乐驾轻就熟，你们有点像是西海岸搞笑版的野兽男孩。嗯，这评价太高了。是啊，哦，谢谢威尔。确实如此。
Very nice. It is true. That's totally true. It's totally true and you were able to do it in such an authentic way too because there are a lot of like sort of white boys from Berkeley who couldn't pull it off and you guys just made it work because you were actually good at it. And God what did I just you know what I saw the other day was one of the video from Bash Brothers, the thing you guys did about the Oakland days.
非常不错。确实如此。完全是这样。完全是这样，而且你们能以一种如此真实的方式做到这一点，因为有许多来自伯克利的白人男孩根本搞不定，而你们却能成功，因为你们真的很擅长。天哪，我刚刚……你知道我前几天看到了什么吗？是巴斯兄弟的一个视频，就是你们关于奥克兰日子的那个作品。
Have you ever seen that you guys? And I can't believe that you pulled it off. What is it? You play Jose Kinseko, Keev plays Mark McGuire and then they do this rap about being on steroids and fucking how small their balls are. And I'm thinking like... Yeah, me and Keev did as kind of just like a side project
你们看过吗？我简直不敢相信你们竟然成功了。那是什么？你扮演何塞·坎塞科，基夫扮演马克·麦奎尔，然后他们合唱了一首关于嗑药和对方的蛋蛋有多小的说唱。我在想……对，我和基夫拍那个纯粹是当成一个副业，
because Yoram was unavailable, so we didn't want to do a proper Lonely Island album without him. Concept album. And then we did like a visual poem, kind of like Lemonade, and very quietly released it on Netflix. And it's Keev is Mark McGuire and I'm Jose Conceco and the whole thing is an album of if the two of them had made a rap record
因为约拉姆没空，所以我们不想在没有他的情况下出一张正经的寂寞岛专辑。概念专辑。然后我们做了一个视觉诗，有点像《柠檬ade》，非常低调地在网飞上发布了。基夫演马克·麦奎尔，我演何塞·坎塞科，整张专辑讲的就是如果这俩人在
in the late 80s during their heyday, what would it have sounded like? I remember being totally fanning out, being so excited and kind of nervous. Sudeikis and I, we were on like a lunch break while we were doing one of the horrible bosses and we were in the valley. And he's like, oh, you know, the guys,
80年代末全盛时期做一张说唱唱片，听起来会是什么样？我记得当时我绝对是迷弟附体，又兴奋又有点紧张。苏戴奇斯和我，我们在拍《恶老板》期间正赶上午休，当时我们在山谷区。然后他说，哦，你知道的，那几个家伙
they rented a house down here. They're recording one of their albums. And he took me over there and it was like noon or something. And we walked in, I think you guys are recording Turtleneck and Chain maybe, right? Yeah. And- Turtleneck and Chain.
在附近租了一栋房子。他们在录制他们的一张专辑。他带着我过去，当时大概中午左右吧。我们走进去，我觉得你们当时可能在录《高领毛衣和铁链》吧？对。还有——《高领毛衣和铁链》。
Yeah. And- That's so good. And I was like, where's Andy? They're like, oh, he's still sleeping. I was like, damn right. Yeah, exactly. They had rented like this colonial style mansion in Encino.
对。还有——太棒了。然后我就问，安迪呢？他们说，哦，他还在睡觉。我说，理当如此。对，没错。他们居然在恩西诺租了一栋殖民地风格的豪宅。
The monstrosity. Yeah, and they just set it up, just like a rock band would, you know, you record in a mansion, but it's usually in the Cotswolds, you know. But this was like off Louise Drive in Encino. But it was pretty awesome to see that. Those summers were so fun. Yeah.
那个庞然大物。对，他们就把设备架好，就像一支摇滚乐队那样，你知道的，在豪宅里录音，不过通常是在科茨沃尔德，你知道的。但这里是恩西诺的路易斯大道附近。不过能看到那个真的挺酷的。那些夏天真是太有趣了。对。
And everyone, the coolest thing about it was how much space we had, and we just put out, like, everyone in comedy come over. That's really cool. And it really happened. Like we have photos of so many of the people that are just the biggest names in comedy now that swung by, because they were like,
每个人，最酷的事情在于我们有那么大的空间，我们只是发出邀请，比如喜剧界的每个人都过来。这真的很酷。而且真的发生了。就像我们有很多照片，上面都是现在喜剧界最大牌的名字，他们都顺道跑了过来，因为他们当时想的
hey, I heard those lonely guys have this stupid house in Encino. Oh, that's great. Right? And we would just drink and have fun and then record songs and knew we were banking them for the next season of SNL. That's so cool.
是，嘿，我听说那几个寂寞岛的家伙在恩西诺有一栋搞笑的房子。哦，太棒了。对吧？我们就会喝酒玩乐，然后录歌，并且知道我们在为新一季的《周六夜现场》储备素材。太酷了。
That's so cool. Do you guys ever talk about getting together and doing another one of those house rentals and just putting down another record? It's tough now because we have kids. Well, they can be in it. Yeah, they can write them in. I don't know that we'll do another house rental ever
太酷了。你们有没有想过聚在一起再租一次那样的房子，然后录一张新唱片？现在很难了，因为我们都有孩子了。嗯，他们可以参与进来。对，可以把他们写进歌里。我不知道我们还会不会再租房子，
unless it's like a compound for all the kids to run around in. Do that. Right. But I definitely think we're gonna try and make more music. I don't think we're done. Look how young your face is.
除非是个能让所有孩子到处乱跑的大院。那就这么办。对。但我绝对觉得我们会尝试创作更多音乐。我不觉得我们已经结束了。看你的脸多年轻。
Kids having kids. Yeah. That's unbelievable. It is funny though, like I always, because Andy, you're younger than I am and then we are, because the three of us are basically the same age. Jason's older, obviously, is that.
孩子生孩子。对。这太不可思议了。不过挺搞笑的，我总是，因为安迪，你比我年轻，然后我们，因为我们三个基本同龄。贾森显然年龄更大，是这样的。
No, just a lot older, but. How old a fellow are you, Andy? I'm 45. Oh, good for you. Yeah. Youngin'. And so now that, like, you've got like, I'll Google it.
不，只是大了很多而已，不过。安迪，你是个多大岁数的小伙子？我45岁。哦，那挺好。年青人。所以现在，就像，你有了，我去谷歌一下。
54. You just seem so young. Oh, really? 53, well, 53. 53, we're 53. You're the coolest. But I have a new penis. did I tell you guys that? Oh, is that true? Yeah, you buried the leaf. Oh, you did it Amazon fucking crazy, right?
54岁。你看起来太年轻了。哦，真的吗？53，好吧，53。53，我们53岁。你最酷了。但我有了一个新的阴茎。我跟你们说过吗？哦，真的吗？对，你把这个重磅消息藏在最后了。哦，你是在亚马逊买的，太疯狂了吧，对吧？
But anyway, sorry, yeah, yeah, yeah We're like rehydrate it. It's like a sea monkey. Well, no, this one's full of moisture. The old one was Spritz bottle I had a fucking Hudson sprayer. It's just enough. So you've got a, you went out and got yourself a new one that you're not gonna use? Yeah. Why don't you just keep not using the old one?
不过总之，抱歉，对，对，对，我们像把它重新泡水一样。它就像个海猴子。好吧，不是，这个充满了水分。旧的那个是个喷雾瓶，我当时有个破哈德逊喷雾器。这就够了。所以你有一个，你出门给自己弄了一个新的，但你不用？对。那你为什么不继续不用旧的那个呢？
Can we get a time check on how long it was since the last dick joke? Can we? I just want to point out I didn't start that one. That was not me, I was not the instigator. I jumped right in. How hard is it for you to not talk about dicks? Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha and when you get home. A fire starts when they decide to make a snack. Do your kids know who to call? Do they know how to say Alexa, call for help? That's all they need to do to be connected
我们能核对一下距离上一个关于丁丁的笑话过去多久了吗？能吗？我只想指出不是我挑起这个话头。那不是我，我不是始作俑者。我只是立刻加入了进去。你忍住不聊丁丁到底有多难？哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈太棒了。
to a dedicated emergency response agent faster than industry standards. Real stories show us time and again, immediate action and information is crucial. Alexa Emergency Assist arms urgent response agents with critical information about you and your family. Additionally, your pre-saved emergency contacts are notified when you call for help and when the call ends.
当孩子们放学回家时。如果他们决定吃点零食，火灾就可能发生。你知道你的孩子们知道该打给谁吗？他们知道怎么说“Alexa，呼叫求助”吗？他们只需这样做，就能比行业标准更快地接通专属的紧急响应人员。真实的故事一次又一次地告诉我们，立即采取行动和获取信息至关重要。“Alexa紧急协助”为紧急响应人员提供关于你和家人的关键信息。此外，当你呼叫求助以及通话结束时，你预存的紧急联系人也会收到通知。
For me, I got so excited when I got it in the mail, I opened it up, I put it on the kitchen island right in the center, because the kitchen's kind of the center of our house, and the comfort and security knowing that the device is sitting in the kitchen, which is the central part of the house, is such a peace of mind thing.
对我来说，当我收到它时我超级兴奋，我把它打开，直接放在厨房岛台的正中央，因为厨房可以说是我家的中心，而且知道设备就放在厨房这个房子的中心位置，那种舒适感和安全感真的很让人安心。
I love knowing it's there, I love having it set up, ready to go, in the case of any emergency. And it's got all of our contacts in there, and Scotty knows it's there, and everybody who's in our lives know it's right there on the center island in our kitchen, ready to use. So it's really kind of a wonderful thing.
我喜欢知道它就在那里，我喜欢把它设置好随时待命，以防万一发生任何紧急情况。它里面存了我们所有的联系人，斯科蒂也知道它在那儿，我们生活中的每个人都知道它就在我们厨房的中央岛台上，随时可以使用。所以这真的是一件非常美妙的事情。
It makes you sleep better at night, knowing that it's there. So for that added layer of protection for your family, property, and even your pets, trust in the peace of mind that only Alexa Emergency Assist can provide. Learn more and subscribe at www.amazon.com slash Alexa Assist. We get support from Helix. Everybody knows we have Helix mattresses
知道它就在那里，能让你晚上睡得更安稳。因此，为了给你的家人、财产甚至宠物提供那多一层保护，请相信只有“Alexa紧急协助”才能带来的安心。了解更多信息并订阅，请访问 www.amazon.com 斜杠 Alexa Assist。我们得到了 Helix 的赞助。大家都知道我们有 Helix 床垫，
and we use them all the time. Why do we use them? Because they work. They are so comfortable, they're so relaxing, they put me to sleep immediately, my head hits the pillow on the mattress. It's fantastic. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress
而且我们一直在使用它们。我们为什么使用它们？因为它们管用。它们太舒服了，太让人放松了，我的头一挨到床垫上的枕头，立刻就能让我入睡。这太棒了。Helix 知道，测试新床垫的最好方法，
than by sleeping on it in your own home. That's why they offer a 100 night trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty. So how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Well, their team created a Helix sleep quiz to help you find your perfect mattress in under two minutes. And your mattress is shipped straight to your door
就是在你自己的家里睡上一觉。这就是为什么他们提供100晚试睡以及10到15年的质保。那么，你怎么知道哪款 Helix 床垫最适合你和你的身体呢？他们的团队为此创建了一个 Helix 睡眠小测验，帮助你在两分钟内找到完美的床垫。而且你的床垫会直接免费
free of charge. I took the quiz and of course, as I mentioned, I got the Dusk Lux because I wanted the perfect night's sleep for me and my body and the way I sleep and the temperature I run. I run a little hotter, I like it cool. So it's actually perfect for me. It's like they read my mind. Helix is offering up to 30% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for
配送到你家门口。我做了这个测试，当然，正如我所提到的，我选择了 Dusk Lux，因为我想要为我自己、我的身体、我的睡眠方式以及我的体温带来完美的睡眠体验。我比较容易发热，我喜欢凉爽的感觉。所以这对我来说简直完美。就像他们能读懂我的心思一样。Helix 为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单高达
our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com. That's helixsleep.com. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With Helix, better sleep starts now. Smartless is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your Sleep starts now. SmartList is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar. Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds,
30% 的折扣以及两个免费枕头。请访问 helixsleep.com。网址是 helixsleep.com。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了 Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。《Smartless》由 Audible 部分赞助播出。在 Audible 上听书能让你的睡眠从现在开始。SmartList 由 Audible 部分赞助播出。在 Audible 上收听能让你的想象力自由翱翔。无论你听的是故事、励志内容、专家建议，还是你喜欢的任何流派，你都能从中获得启发，去想象新的世界、
new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audiobooks, podcasts, and originals that members can listen to all they want with more added all the time. Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time. There's more to imagine when you listen. I've
新的可能性、新的思维方式。寻找你喜欢的流派，并在沿途发现新的流派。探索畅销书、新书上架，以及数千部包含在内的有声书、播客和原创作品，会员可以随心所欲地收听，并且不断有新内容加入。Audible 让你在日常生活中轻松获得启发和娱乐，无需特意腾出额外时间。当你聆听时，有更多值得想象的空间。我
been listening to Dune. Why? Because I love it. I love the movie so much I was like I actually want to go back and I've never read the book I've never heard the book I should say and so it's really cool they have all these people narrating it different different characters it's really cool to have all these people narrating it, different characters. It's really cool, and if you're a fan of Dune and Arrakis, I'm learning about Arrakis. And Frank Herbert, who wrote it, it's much more descriptive than the movie,
一直在听《沙丘》。为什么？因为我太喜欢了。我太喜欢这部电影了，以至于我想回过头去看看，而且我从来没读过这本书，从来没听过这本书，我应该这么说，所以有这么多人来为它配音真的很酷，不同的角色，有这么多不同的角色来为它配音真的很酷。如果你是《沙丘》和阿拉基斯的粉丝，我正在了解阿拉基斯。还有原著作者弗兰克·赫伯特，它比电影描述得要详细得多，
even though the movie's fantastic. But to hear all the words and how he describes everything, and you go, oh yeah, I remember that. It's really, really cool. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days.
尽管电影已经非常棒了。但听到所有的文字以及他是如何描述这一切的，你会觉得，“哦，对，我想起来了。”这真的非常非常酷。作为 Audible 会员，你可以从整个目录中选择一本作品永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。新会员可以免费体验 Audible 30 天。
Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. Hey, smartless crew. I've been drinking AG1 since 2020.
访问 audible.com 斜杠 smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。网址是 audible.com 斜杠 smartless，或者发送短信 smartless 到 500-500，即可免费体验 Audible 30 天。audible.com 斜杠 smartless。嘿，《Smartless》的伙伴们。我从2020年开始一直在喝 AG1。
It's become my daily go-to foundational nutrition supplement. Really, I trust AG1 because it's not just about what's in it, but what's not. Catch my drift? AG1 is rigorously tested for 950 impurities way beyond the industry norm. Seriously, it's a game changer for me. I feel the difference daily. What I love about it is it's so easy. You can make a smoothie and just dump it in
它已经成了我每天必不可真的基础营养补充剂。真的，我信任 AG1 不仅是因为它里面含有什麽，更是因为它不含什麽。懂我的意思吗？AG1 经过了严格的杂质检测，检测项目高达950种，远超行业标准。说真的，它对我的改变太大了。我每天都能感受到这种不同。我最喜欢它的一点是它太简单了。你可以做个冰沙，然后直接把粉倒进去，
with all the other stuff in your smoothie, or you can just mix it with water and take it on the go, and your body's getting all the vitamins and minerals that you could possibly need. Instead of taking a bunch of supplements and buying all that healthy food that you'd have to eat, it's just AG1 all in one drink. Now, let's get into the good stuff.
和冰沙里的所有其他东西混在一起，或者你也可以直接把它和水混合，随时随地带走，你的身体就能获得可能需要的所有维生素和矿物质。不用吃一大堆补充剂，也不用去买那些你不得不吃的健康食品，一杯 AG1 就能搞定一切。好了，让我们进入正题。
Why AG1? It's a powerhouse for major body systems with ingredients like vitamin C and zinc, which helps me make my immune health in tip-top shape. AG1 is the supplement I trust to provide the support my body needs daily, and that's why they've been a partner for so long. If you take just one thing, let it be AG1.
为什麽要选 AG1？它是一个关乎人体各大系统的营养能量库，里面含有维生素C和锌等成分，这有助于将我的免疫健康保持在最佳状态。AG1 是我信任的能够为我的身体提供日常所需支持的补充剂，这也是他们能成为长期合作伙伴的原因。如果你只要吃一样东西，那就选 AG1 吧。
Try AG1 and get a free one-year supply of vitamin D3K2 and five free AG1 travel packs with your first purchase. Go to drinkag1.com slash smart list so they know we sent you. That's drinkag1.com slash smart list. Check it out. All right, back to the show. Andy, I wanna talk to you about growing, no, when you were a kid, because I read this
尝试 AG1，并在首次购买时获赠价值一年的维生素 D3K2 以及五包免费的 AG1 便携装。请访问 drinkag1.com 斜杠 smart list，让他们知道是我们介绍你来的。网址是 drinkag1.com 斜杠 smart list。快去看看吧。好了，回到节目中。安迪，我想跟你聊聊你的成长，不对，是你小时候的事情，因为我读过一
thing where you wrote a letter to your eight-year-old self, which, what was that about? And were you into comedy at such a young age that you knew that you wanted to do it even at eight years old? Yes. I mean, I have said forever, and it's really genuinely true that at eight I just said that I wanted to be on SNL specifically. Oh my God, that's great. I love that.
篇你写给八岁自己的信，那是怎麽回事？你是不是在很小的时候就对喜剧感兴趣，以至于八岁时就知道自己想做这个了？是的。我的意思是，我一直以来都这么说，而且这绝对是千真万确的，八岁的时候我就说过，我只想上《周六夜现场》。哦天哪，太棒了。我太喜欢这个了。
I used to, I was into WWF Wrestling, and there was that show called Saturday Night's Main Event, which was on once a month. We don't need to tell Tracy about that one, huh? Yeah. I didn't know what Saturday Yep Missed it
我以前，我迷恋过WWF摔角，当时有个节目叫《周六夜主赛》，一个月播一次。我们不用跟特蕾西提那个吧，哈？对。我不知道周六——没错，错过了
First reference we haven't had to explain So speaking to the demo she's quietly nodding there in Chicago right continue and She's saying continue. Got it. Oh my God. But yeah, so the nights that it wasn't on was SNL. So I found it by accident as a kid and watched it. And it was, you know, love its carvy era.
这是我们第一个不用解释的梗。所以这是迎合受众的，她正在芝加哥默默点头呢，好，继续，而且她在说继续。明白了。天哪。不过话说回来，没播的那几天就是《周六夜现场》。所以作为小屁孩的我偶然发现了它并看了起来。而且你知道的，那是卡维的时代。
And you wrote a letter saying, doing like what, of goals or something? Oh no, I think it was like a school assignment where it was like fill in the blank thing and it was like when I am older I will be and I was like a comedian obviously. Was there ever a moment where it got emotional for you on Saturday Night Live, either your first performance or your last one or?
你写过一封信，上面写着类似目标之类的内容？哦不，我想那大概是个学校作业，类似于填空题那种，上面写着“当我长大后，我会成为”，然后我当时就填了“喜剧演员”，显而易见。在《周六夜现场》里，有没有哪个时刻让你感到情绪激动，无论是你的第一次表演还是最后一次，或者别的什么？
Oh my God, the whole time. Yeah, I'll bet. The feeling of I'm living inside of actual dreams I've had. Yeah. And now I'm friends with people that I would meet in my dreams. Right. That were cast members on the show
天哪，一直都是。是啊，我敢打赌。那种感觉就像是我正生活在自己做过的真实梦境里。对。而且现在我和那些我只会在梦里遇到的人成为了朋友。没错。他们曾是这个节目的卡司
and then I got on the show and they were still working there because we watched every episode. It was my absolute obsession. That's so great. And then now I'm like, oh yeah, now I just like chat with them whenever. And you're part of that fraternity now of people who are on it, and it is a very sort of tight knit, no matter, it's kind of like a... You see each other, you can give a nod or you can say hey,
然后我加入了节目，他们当时还在那儿工作，因为我们每一集都看。那是我的绝对狂热。太棒了。然后现在我就觉得，哦对，现在我随时都能跟他们闲聊了。而且你现在也是那个由曾经的卡司成员组成的兄弟会的一员了，那是一个非常紧密的圈子，无论如何，它有点像……你们看到彼此，可以点头致意或者打个招呼，
because it's the smallest demo, right? Like, I mean, it's just the tiniest percentage of people who've ever been cast members in the show. Yes. Was it what you thought it would be? Or, I mean, answer that just the tiniest percentage of people who've ever been cast members in the show. Yeah. Was it what you thought it would be? Or, I mean, answer that, but then also, what was the most surprising part of it, or the part that really kind of floored you,
因为这是最小的受众群体，对吧？我是说，这只占所有曾在节目中担任过卡司成员的人极小的一个百分比。是的。它和你想象的一样吗？或者说，回答这个问题，但同时，最让人惊讶的部分是什么，或者说真正让你惊艳到、
like that you didn't really imagine? I think it was similar to what I was expecting, because I had read so much about it, but the thing I wasn't expecting was for it, and I genuinely mean this, for it to go so well for us. The whole cast. Having watched it and having seen how hard it is, especially in terms of how quickly,
可以说是你完全没想到的部分是什么？我想这和我的预期差不多，因为我读过太多关于它的资料了，但我没料到的是——我是真心这么觉得的——它对我们来说会进展得如此顺利。整个制作团队。看过了它，也见识了它的难度有多大，尤其是考虑到速度有多快，
because the thing about SNL generally, unless you're one of 10 people, is you have to ingratiate yourself to the SNL generally, unless you're like one of 10 people, is you have to like ingratiate yourself to the SNL audience and give them time and space to figure out what you do that is funny and why. Yeah, it's very smart of you, yeah, for sure. And so for us, speaking to what we were just talking about with Lazy Sunday, that was a crazy shortcut
因为《周六夜现场》通常的情况是，除非你是那十个人之一，否则你必须得讨好——《周六夜现场》通常的情况是，除非你是那十个人之一，否则你必须得讨好《周六夜现场》的观众，给他们时间和空间去弄清楚你搞笑的地方在哪里，以及为什么好笑。是的，你这招很聪明，对，确实如此。所以对于我们来说，结合我们刚才聊到的《慵懒的主日》，那绝对是一条疯狂的捷径，
to the path I thought we were on. Like when Lazy Sunday aired, Will, you asked, and I didn't answer it, what was it like when you guys were in the studio when that aired? We were not thinking like, we did it! We were just like, oh, we got something on. I'm so relieved we're not gonna get fired. Because it was the world halfway into our first season.
通往我以为我们在走的道路。就像《慵懒的主日》播出的那天，威尔，你问过我——而我没有回答——当你们在录音室看到它播出时，是什么感觉？我们当时并没有觉得：我们成功了！我们只是觉得：哦，我们有个节目播出了。我太欣慰了，我们不会被炒鱿鱼了。因为那是我们第一季过半的时候。
And then when did it start to dawn on you that, oh, this thing caught on? Like, was it the next day when you woke up from the after party, like you saw online that there was some traffic about it? Yes. And the press part of it. Like, we immediately were, like, in touch with the NBC PR people.
然后什么时候你开始意识到，哦，这玩意儿火了？比如，是庆功宴醒来的第二天，你在网上看到关于它的各种浏览量的时候吗？是的。还有媒体报道这部分。就像我们立刻就和NBC的公关人员联系上了。
Which, I was like, oh, I don't know anything about this world. And they're like, hey, New York Times wants to talk to you. You guys free right now? We were just like, okay. Geez, sure. About what? We sure are. But you know, everybody always talks to you about those shorts,
对此我当时心想，哦，我对这个世界一无所知。然后他们说：“嘿，《纽约时报》想采访你们。你们现在有空吗？”我们当时就想：“好吧。天哪，当然有。关于什么？当然有。”不过你知道的，每个人总是跟你聊那些短片，
but I loved tons of stuff that you did, but I loved the impressions you did. Mark Zuckerberg, Nick Cage, Mark Wahlberg, Hugh Jackman. Was there a celebrity of somebody you did that you heard from about any of your impressions? I mean, the one that was the most gratifying was Cage for me. Nick Cage?
但我超级喜欢你做过的很多东西，我特别喜欢你的模仿。马克·扎克伯格、尼古拉斯·凯奇、马克·沃尔伯格、休·杰克曼。有没有哪个你模仿的名人亲自联系过你，谈谈你对他们的模仿？我是说，最让人感到欣慰的模仿对象对我来说是凯奇。尼古拉斯·凯奇？
Because he came on and did it with me. Yes, I remember that. And the Cage thing, and he was so cool about it and he did not have to be, because we were like, doing a psychotic character and saying he was Nick Cage. You know what I mean? It was like, and I was, and still am, and we all are a massive fan of Nick Cage,
因为他亲自上节目跟我一起演了。对，我记得那个。模仿凯奇那次，他表现得太酷了，而且他完全没必要这么做，因为我们当时是在扮演一个精神病角色，还说那就是尼古拉斯·凯奇。你知道我的意思吗？当时的感觉就是，我以前是，现在依然是，我们所有人都一直是尼古拉斯·凯奇的超级粉丝，
and I've seen so many of his movies, and that's how it ended up being something I could do, because I was like, I've seen him talk so much. Yeah, yeah. Well, that's the thing, too, is that you made... You didn't make fun of, but you poked fun at certain elements, but you never punched down. It was always people who were massive,
我看过他那么多电影，这也是为什么这最终成了我能模仿的东西，因为我觉得，我看过他说了那么多话。对，对。好吧，这就是重点所在，你并没有……你没有取笑，而是开玩笑地调侃了某些元素，但你从来没有落井下石。对象总是那些大人物，
whether it was Nick Cage, you did... Wahlberg came on, I remember he came on as well, as you were doing, say hello to your mother for me. Like, again, you're punching up, like, you're making a joke because he's such a massive movie star, right? Yes. And by the way, that way, when you're on SNL, this is the thing I always think about, because I'm like, I never got into comedy
无论是尼古拉斯·凯奇，还是你模仿的……沃尔伯格也来了，我记得他也来了，就像你当时说的“替我向你母亲问好”。同样，你是在向上社交，你在开玩笑是因为他是如此巨大的电影明星，对吧？是的。顺便说一句，当你在《周六夜现场》的时候，这就是我经常想的事情，因为我觉得，我当初进喜剧界可不是为了
to do impressions or make fun of anyone. Obviously amongst my friends, we'll talk shit about literally anything. And anybody. But when you're on the show, impressions are such a, it's such currency, right? And you know it plays, and you know it'll get on,
去模仿别人或者取笑任何人。当然，在朋友之间，我们什么都吐槽，任何人都可以。但当你上了节目，模仿绝对是一种硬通货，对吧？你知道它吃香，你知道它能播，
and you're just desperately trying to get on. So if you do one that works and everyone's laughing at, it's hard to be like, no, I'm not gonna do that. I don't feel good about it morally. Did you have to do it for your audition? Did you have to do impressions? Yes. Yeah? For your audition, Did you have to do impressions? Yes. Yeah.
而你当时只是在拼命想要露脸。所以如果你搞出了一个管用、大家都笑的前端模仿，你很难说：“不，我不打算这么干。从道德上讲我感觉不好。”你面试的时候必须得做这个吗？你必须得模仿吗？是的。是吗？面试的时候，你得模仿吗？是的。是吗？
For your audition, they asked you to do characters and impressions. And when I got asked, by the way, I had been doing standup, but I had no impressions or characters. So we wrote them all leading up to the audition. Oh wow. What was your go-to impression at that time?
面试时，他们要求你表演角色和模仿。而当时当他们提出要求时，顺便说一句，我一直在演单口喜剧，但我没有任何模仿或角色储备。所以我们在面试前把它们全都写出来了。哦，天哪。那时候你最拿手的模仿是什么？
Honestly, by chance, it was Fallon because I did the Temp Fallon voice on the movie awards for the storyboards of the pre-tape we wrote. And then Jimmy, who is the nicest and was so nice to us, he really helped put us on. But he heard me in the Temp VO of the animatic, which is the storyboards of whatever it was, and it was me being like, oh my god, we gotta go, Batman.
老实说，纯属偶然，是吉米·法伦，因为我在电影奖上为我们写的预录制脚本的分镜做临时配音时，用了临时法伦的声音。然后吉米——他是个最好的人，对我们特别好——他真的帮了我们一把。但他听到了我在动画分镜（也就是那些分镜脚本）里的临时配音，当时是我在说：“哦天哪，我们得走了，蝙蝠侠。”
And he was like, who's doing my voice? Oh my god, it's so funny. And so they were like, even Higgins was like, hey, when you audition, you should do Jimmy. And I was like, oh. Really? So I did Jimmy Fallon at a funeral. But he was like, oh my god, I'm so sad.
然后他说：“谁在模仿我的声音？哦天哪，太搞笑了。”所以他们就说，连希金斯都说：“嘿，你面试的时候，应该模仿吉米。”然后我就想：“哦。真的吗？”于是我在葬礼上模仿了吉米·法伦。但他当时表现得就像是：“哦天哪，我太难过了。”
At a funeral is really funny. Oh my god, McClay and thanks. And they're like, okay. This guy can't do impressions. I love that. I love that so much. So wait, so tell me about how, you know, I did that little thing with you, the Maya Rudolph show. And you made me pee in my pants. We had fun, Sean. Tell me about how, you know, I did that little thing with you, the Maya Rudolph show. And you made me pee in my pants.
在葬礼上模仿真的太搞笑了。哦天哪，麦克雷，谢啦。然后他们就觉得：“好吧。这家伙不会模仿。”我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢这个了。等等，那么告诉我，你知道的，我和你一起做过那个小节目，玛娅·鲁道夫秀。你让我笑尿了裤子。我们玩得很开心，肖恩。告诉我，你知道的，我和你一起做过那个小节目，玛娅·鲁道夫秀。你让我笑尿了裤子。
So. We had fun, Sean. Oh my God, I laughed so hard with you. I was crying laughing. And so many bits came out of that. But you told me about your wife, and you're like, you know, you're a musician, Sean. My wife plays the harp and she sings.
所以。我们玩得很开心，肖恩。天哪，跟你在一起我笑得太厉害了。我都笑哭了。很多段子就是这么诞生的。但你跟我聊起你妻子，你说，你知道的，你是个音乐家，肖恩。我妻子弹竖琴还唱歌。
I'm like, oh, who's your wife? And Joanne, as you told me, Joanne is, and I downloaded her album, and I was like, oh, who's your wife? And Joanne, as you told me, Joanne is, and I downloaded her album and I was like, oh my God, this woman's amazing. I fell in love with her right away. Do you guys work on music stuff together? Do you check in with her? How does that work?
我就想，哦，你妻子是谁？然后如你所告诉我的，乔安妮是，我下载了她的专辑，然后我就想，哦，你妻子是谁？然后如你所告诉我的，乔安妮是，我下载了她的专辑，然后我就想，哦天哪，这女人太棒了。我立刻就爱上她了。你们俩会一起合作音乐方面的事情吗？你会向她请教吗？那是怎么运作的？
We don't work on music together because, yeah. Mine's pretend and hers is arguably amongst the best ever, in my opinion. She's fantastic. Tell me about her. What is it? Does she play in an orchestra? No, no. Her name's Joanna Newsom. She's a singer-songwriter who plays harp and piano and sings at the same time. Yeah, Jay, you would love, would love it. She's so good. I'm such a fan. You know I'm a fan. Yes.
我们不一起合作音乐，因为，对吧。我的音乐是假装的，而她的可以说是史上最棒的音乐之一，依我之见。她棒极了。跟我说说她。是什么？她是在乐团里演奏吗？不，不。她叫乔安娜·纽瑟姆。她是一位创作型歌手，同时弹竖琴、钢琴并演唱。对的，杰伊，你会喜欢的，绝对会喜欢。她太优秀了。我是她的超级粉丝。你知道我是粉丝。是的。
I mean, we met because I was at her concert with Fred and our friend, Matt Murray, because I was obsessed with her music. Is that true? Yeah. You, Fred and the Panther. Yeah. Wait, who's the Panther? Our writer friend, Matt Murray.
我是说，我们相遇是因为我和弗雷德还有我们的朋友马特·默里一起去看了她的演唱会，因为我当时对她的音乐着迷得不行。真的吗？对。你、弗雷德和“黑豹”。等下，“黑豹”是谁？我们的编剧朋友马特·默里。
I forget who dubbed him the Panther, maybe like Spivey or someone. Somebody like that. Or Dratch possibly, that he would sit in the corner quietly and then... Yeah, when somebody goes like, oh, that's the Panther, you're like, that's the Panther. But because he would lay in the cut and wait and then strike with his joke that would kill everybody after... So funny.
我忘了是谁给他起了个绰号叫“黑豹”，可能是斯派维或者谁吧。差不多是这样的人。或者可能是德拉奇，他会静静地坐在角落里，然后……对，当有人说“哦，那是黑豹”时，你就会觉得“那就是黑豹”。因为他总是潜伏在暗处等待，然后用一个能把所有人都笑死的笑话一击致命……太搞笑了。
Yeah. So you're at Joanna's concert and you wiggle your way backstage as a creepy fan and And and somehow get her your number No, it wasn't she we just met and hung out all together that night just friendly style but Fred had met her and her friends at a at a music festival that he had been at I guess in the summer previous and and her and her friends at a music festival that he had been at, I guess, in the summer previous. And it just worked out. Like, I had been listening to her albums for years and been to her show before even. But when I met her, it turned out she and her siblings had watched Lonely Island stuff, so it was very comfortable and not as creepy as I was.
对。所以你在乔安娜的演唱会上，像个可怕的狂热粉丝一样潜入后台，然后设法把你的电话号码塞给了她？不，不是的，我们那天晚上只是碰巧一起聚了聚，很友好的那种风格，不过弗雷德曾在前一年夏天的某个音乐节上见过她和她的朋友们，然后就这么顺理成章了。我听她的专辑好几年了，甚至在那之前就去看过她的演出。但当我见到她时，原来她和她的兄弟姐妹们都看过寂寞岛的节目，所以感觉非常自然，不像我表现得那么像个跟踪狂。
I love that. And then you fell in love and you made babies and here we are. Whoa, whoa. You don't wanna talk about the lovely stuff. Shawn. How they make babies. You wanna talk about, hey, did anybody ever forget a line during a live taping of, tell me, could you ever not read. Oh, you know I love that. Could you ever not read the cards, Andy?
我太喜欢这个了。然后你们坠入爱河，生了小宝宝，然后就有了今天。哇，哇。你不想聊聊这些温馨的事吗？肖恩。他们是怎么生出宝宝的。你想聊的是，嘿，有没有人在直播期间忘词过，告诉我，你有没有过读不出提词卡的时候，安迪？
I love those stories. Did someone ever get in your way between you and the cards? You know, I love those stories. Did someone ever get in your way between you and the carts? You know, I love that. If you have a biggest flub SNL story, I live for them. But if you don't, that's fine. I mean, I do have one, but it's not that crazy. No? Okay, well what is it?
我太喜欢那些故事了。有没有人挡在你和提词卡之间？你知道的，我太喜欢这些故事了。有没有人挡在你和提词卡之间？你知道的，我太喜欢这个了。如果你有最严重的SNL直播口误故事，我就是为这个活着的。但如果你没有，那也没关系。我是说，我确实有一个，但其实没那么疯狂。没有？好吧，那是怎么回事？
I was standing underneath the main part of the bleachers, like the main walk that you do towards the main stage. And Seinfeld was on, I think he did really with Seth on update. And he stopped and started talking to me and I was like, holy shit. So we were just chatting and I was like, oh yeah, Seinfeld, and I was like, yeah, this and that.
我当时站在看台主要部分的下方，也就是通往主舞台的那条主要通道。宋飞当时在节目里，我想他是在“周末更新”环节和塞思搭档得非常好。他停下来开始跟我说话，我当时想：卧槽。所以我们就在那儿闲聊，我说：“哦对了，宋飞，”我还说：“对啊，这啊那啊的。”
And then I was like, I looked up at, you know, they have monitors all backstage showing you what's airing. And I just like casually look up and I was like, yeah, this and that. And then I was like, I looked up at, they have monitors all backstage showing you what's airing. And I just casually look up and I'm like, oh, I'm in this sketch and it just started. Oh my God, no way. I was like, I'm so sorry, and just took off running. And it was a courtroom sketch.
然后我就想——我抬头看了看，你知道的，后台到处都有监视器向你展示正在播出的节目。我只是随口抬头看了一眼，然后我说：“对啊，这啊那啊的。”然后我就想——我抬头看了一眼，后台到处都有监视器向你展示正在播出的节目。我只是随口抬头看了一眼，心想：哦，我在这段小品里，而且它刚开始播。天哪，不会吧。我当时想：太对不起了，然后拔腿就跑。那是一个法庭小品。
I missed getting on before it started. They stopped me and said, no! Because I was going to try and run on. Totally, by fortune's fucking hell, who knows? I had had one line at the top of the sketch and they had cut it between dress and air and no one had told me. So I actually didn't screw up the sketch,
在它开始之前我没赶上登台。他们拦住我并说：“不行！”因为我本来打算试着跑上去。完全是凭着该死的运气，谁知道呢？我在小品开头本该有一句台词，结果他们在彩排和直播之间把它剪掉了，却没有人告诉我。所以其实我并没有搞砸这个小品，
but I did have my nightmare that I had every week that time working there and still now have where I'm backstage and I can't find the set. I can't find stage and I'm in a sketch and I can't get there and I see it on the monitor and it actually happened, but I got very lucky. Actors' Nightmare, I love very lucky. Actors Nightmare. I love those stories.
但我确实经历了我在那儿工作期间每周都会做、现在也偶尔会做的噩梦：我在后台找不到布景。我找不到舞台，而我正在一个小品里，却怎么也上不去，我能在监视器上看到它正在演，而这竟然真的发生了，不过我非常幸运。演员的噩梦，我喜欢这种非常幸运。演员的噩梦。我太喜欢这些故事了。
Wait, now Palm Springs is one of my favorite movies. I love that movie. When I saw it come out, I was like, oh, Andy's in a gay film. And then it wasn't gay at all. Another one? Bennett Barbekel's brother. So as you know, Bennett, who is part of our team, I'm gonna say hi.
等等，现在《棕榈泉》是我最喜欢的电影之一。我太喜欢那部电影了。我看到它上映的时候，我就想：哦，安迪演了一部同性恋电影。结果它一点也不基。另一个？贝内特·巴尔贝基尔的兄弟。如你所知，贝内特是我们团队的一员，我要打个招呼。
It's his brother directed, as you know. Yes, I do. Love that movie. Loved hi, it's his brother, directed as you know. Yes, I do. Love that movie, loved you in it. So good. I love that movie. That movie is so good, and I tell anybody, it's one of my favorite films of the last 10 years,
正如你所知，是他的兄弟执导的。是的，我知道。太喜欢那部电影了。太喜欢了——嘿，正如你所知，是他的兄弟执导的。是的，我知道。太喜欢那部电影了，太喜欢你在里面的表现了。太棒了。我太喜欢那部电影了。那部电影太棒了，我跟谁都说，那是过去十年里我最喜欢的电影之一，
so needs more attention, so unheralded. You're so funny and profoundly good and kind of sad, like it's the perfect blend of, I just love that movie. Thank you, I love it too. Any it's the perfect blend of, I just love that movie. Thank you. I love it too. Any truth to the sequel rumors, Palm Desert? No? Death Valley.
所以它需要更多的关注，它实在是太被埋没了。你太搞笑了，深沉而又出色，还有点小忧伤，就像是完美的融合，我太爱那部电影了。谢谢，我也很喜欢。续集的传闻有什么内幕吗，《棕榈沙漠》？没有？《死亡谷》。
It's Palmdale. Palmdale. Indian Wells. And Andy, you have a new podcast with Seth Meyers called The Lonely Island, The Seth Meyers Podcast. Right? That's right. And how did it start? Are you excited?
是《帕姆代尔》。帕姆代尔。印第安维尔斯。安迪，你和塞思·迈尔斯合作了一个新播客，叫《寂寞岛与塞思·迈尔斯播客》。对吧？没错。它是怎么开始的？你兴奋吗？
Has it started? Tell us everything. Well, me and Keev and Yoram forever, especially during COVID, and we didn't jump on it like you smart guys, we're like, we should do one. It'll make it that we get to see each other and talk all the time.
已经开始了吗？快给我们讲讲全部。好吧，我和基夫还有约拉姆一直都在一起，尤其是在疫情期间，我们当时没有像你们这些聪明人那样立刻行动，我们只是觉得：我们应该做一个。这样我们就能经常见面并一直聊天了。
We should do one where we talk about the digital shorts and every episode can be a digital short and what was going on in our lives and at SNL that week when we did the digital short. And then because we're us, we kind of just let it drift. And then Seth called us and was like, hey, I just had an idea. How would you guys feel about doing a podcast
我们应该做个播客，聊聊数字短片，每一集都可以围绕一个数字短片展开，聊聊我们当时的生活，以及我们在SNL制作那个短片的那周发生了什么。然后因为我们就是我们，我们就开始有点随性而为了。接着塞思给我们打电话说：“嘿，我刚有个想法。你们觉得做个播客怎么样？
where every episode is about one of the digital shorts and what was going on at the show that week, and I'll host it, and my team will organize it, and you guys just show up and do it? And I'll take half. Yeah. Yeah. And he'll take, yeah.
每一集都关于其中一个数字短片以及当时节目周发生的事情，我来主持，我的团队来组织，你们俩只管出现并录制就行？”“我拿一半。”对。对。而他拿，对。
No, he's got his good 80%. But I mean, he's late night. No, but it's late night. And he's a good guy. Like when other people aren't around, he's nice to me. He's like, I love that. Why, we gotta check it out. It sounds like- That's so fun.
不，他拿了他那优渥的80%。但我是说，他是深夜秀。不，但那是深夜秀。而且他是个好人。当别人不在场的时候，他对我都挺好的。他就说：“我太喜欢这个了。”为什么，我们得去看看。听起来——太有趣了。
So that's coming on soon. What's it called? The Lonely Island and Seth Meyers podcast? Yeah, we debated that name Yeah, I guess I see why why cuz it rolls off the While to get that one, what sounds like a huge argument What's your favorite Andy what we I know it's, but what's your favorite digital short that you guys did? When it's all said and done. I love the boat one on the boat.
所以那个很快就要推出了。叫什么名字？《寂寞岛与塞思·迈尔斯播客》？对，我们讨论过这个名字。对，我大概明白为什么了——为什么？因为说起来很顺口。为了定下这个名字花了点时间，听起来像是一场激烈的争论。安迪，你最喜欢的——我们都知道，但你们制作的最喜欢的数字短片是什么？当尘埃落定之后。我最喜欢那部在船上的。
Thank you. I'm On A Boat I think is the biggest selling song we ever did. Is it really? Yeah. I'm On A Boat. What's your personal favorite? Double platinum or something stupid.
谢谢。《我在船上》我想是我们制作过销量最高的歌曲。真的吗？对。《我在船上》。你个人最喜欢的是哪个？双白金销量还是什么的蠢歌。
That's incredible. My favorite, if I had to just pick one out of thin air, probably Jack Sparrow with Michael Bolton. Yeah. Sure. And the reason I would give, and we do generally say this one, and the reason is because it's sort of a confluence
太不可思议了。如果我非得凭空挑一个的话，我最喜欢的可能是迈克尔·博尔顿客串的《杰克·斯帕罗》。对。当然。我会给出这个理由的原因——我们通常也确实这么说——原因在于它是各种元素的交汇点。
of all the ones. So it's like people who really love comedy ride for it. Like I've been told that like writers rooms have watched it all together and enjoyed it, which is the highest compliment. And then also it sounds pretty good and the video's big and slick and it feels like big business,
所以它就像是那些真正热爱喜剧的人会为之疯狂的作品。有人告诉我，编剧室曾把这首歌放在一起反复观看并乐在其中，这是最高的赞美。而且它听起来也相当不错，视频画面宏大流畅，给人一种大制作的感觉，
which is something else that we were able to pull off. That's really like big business. I would say my favorite personally, of the digital short, and I'm a, as you know, a massive fan of them all. And I embarrass you all the time because I just tell you all the time how much I love the, but Dear Sister. Oh, nice. That's good.
这也是我们能够成功实现的另一大成果。这真的很像大制作。要说我个人最喜欢的数字短片，正如你所知，我是所有这些短片的超级粉丝。我经常让你感到尴尬，因为我总是不断地对你说我有多喜欢那个——但《亲爱的姐姐》是个例外。哦，不错。那个挺好。
Dear Sister for me scratches and itch because it just keeps going. But it's got a real story to it. I love non-musical one too. I mean I guess it is still music. It's still kind of musical. It's not your original music, but it's musical. But there's something about it.
对我来说，《亲爱的姐姐》完美地戳中了我的痒点，因为它剧情一直在推进。但它有一个真正的主线故事。我也喜欢非音乐类的。我是说它其实还是有音乐。它某种程度上还是带音乐的。虽然不是你们的原创新音乐，但它确实有音乐性。不过它有一种特殊的魅力。
Yeah. Dear Sister was an idea that we had started shooting before we got SNL. Oh wow. Yeah, me and Yoram I think, and my friend Chester, Chester Tam. Because it's originally based on this moment from the end of an episode of that show, The O.C.,
对。《亲爱的姐姐》这个创意我们在加入SNL之前就已经开始拍摄了。哦，哇。对，我想是我和约拉姆，还有我的朋友切斯特·谭。因为它最初的灵感来自那部剧《橘子郡男孩》某一集结尾的一个场景，
which we loved. Yeah. Of course. Where the character, Marissa, shoots someone and it cranks into slo-mo and that song comes on and it's those slo-mo shots of everyone's face being shocked that it's happened and someone falls out of frame and you're like,
我们当时非常喜欢那部剧。对。当然。剧中角色玛丽莎开枪射击了某人，画面瞬间切入慢动作，那首歌随之响起，接着就是所有人脸上震惊表情的慢动作特写，看着事情就这么发生了，有人倒出镜头外，你会觉得：
oh my God, what just happened? It's a slow reveal and I remember us being like, that was fucking good TV and what is that song? So then I was like, what do we do? We do the same thing over and over again and then make it go faster and faster. So we started doing it but but never even finished it. And then I love that that is one that you like, Will,
天哪，刚刚发生了什么？这是一个缓缓揭晓的过程，我记得当时我们觉得：这特么才叫好电视，这首歌到底是什么？于是我当时就在想：我们要怎么做？我们把同样的动作一遍又一遍地重复，然后让节奏越来越快。所以我们开始拍了，但甚至都没拍完。不过我很高兴这是你喜欢的作品，威尔，
because for us that week it was like out of desperation, we said, oh man, let's just try that, and then we'll just write an ending for it. And we wrote like way more and actually ended up like. Well the cast, first of all, the cast, if you look at our paper is insane. So it's you and it's Shia LaBeouf and it's Wig and Sudeikis and Fred and Hader.
因为对我们来说，那周的情况纯粹是出于绝望，我们说：“哦天哪，不如就试试这个吧，然后我们随便写个结局就行。”结果我们写得远比想象的多，最后竟然……不过说实话，演员阵容——首先，演员阵容，如果你看看我们的名单，简直疯狂。有你，有希亚·拉博夫，有韦格，有苏戴奇斯，有弗雷德，还有哈德尔。
Like, it's a freaking murderer's row of cast. I loved our cast. Yeah. It was really fun to get to work with that group. Yeah, I did too. And you know what, Andy? I have to say how you looked forward to Saturday to work with that group. Yeah, I did too. And you know what, Andy, I have to say how you looked forward to Saturday Night Live as a kid,
简直就像是一份全明星杀手级的卡司阵容。我爱死我们的卡司了。对。能和那个团队一起工作真的太有趣了。是的，我也是。你知道吗，安迪？我不得不说，正如你小时候期待《周六夜现场》来和那个团队合作一样，
I looked forward to your digital shorts watching Saturday Night Live in the same way. Yeah, every single week. And now it continues to other things, like when I saw you in Palm Springs, I was like, oh my God, another movie that Andy's doing. I just can't get enough of it. This has been life-affirming, frankly. I wasn't expecting it to be this nice.
我当年看《周六夜现场》时，也同样期待着你的数字短片。真的，每一周都期待。现在这种感觉延续到了其他作品上，比如当我在《棕榈泉》里看到你时，我就想：哦天哪，安迪又出了一部电影。我简直看不够。坦白说，这真的是一种重塑人生的体验。我没想到它会这么棒。
It's true. It's true. Andy, it's totally true that you are one of... You truly are one of the good guys because you're, A, supernaturally funny. You can't help it. You have no choice. And, B, you're very generous and you're very sweet. And any success and all the success you have had and will continue to have, you have completely earned it. There's no hiding what you, anyway, so it's just awesome. I'm just psyched, I just think you're a great dude. And we're so grateful you came today,
真的。千真万确。安迪，千真万确，你绝对是……你真的是个大好人，因为第一，你自带超能力般的幽默感。你根本控制不住。你别无选择。第二，你非常慷慨，非常贴心。你所获得的一切成功以及将要获得的全部成功，都是你完全凭实力得来的。这没什么好掩饰的，不管怎样，总之太棒了。我太兴奋了，我真的觉得你是个绝佳的家伙。我们非常感激你今天能来，
so thank you for coming on our little show. Guys, we're industry staples. Yeah, yeah, sure. We're not going anywhere. We did it. We did it. We did it. Game over.
所以谢谢你来参加我们这个小节目。伙计们，我们可是行业中流砥柱。对，对，当然。我们哪儿也不去。我们成功了。我们成功了。我们成功了。游戏结束。
But also with that, the caveat being, you know, your next bomb, I'm gonna be the first there to say, you bombed. Well guess what? We didn't talk about the box office on Hot Rod. We just skimmed right past that. Oh, we didn't talk about that. Yeah, that's true.
但话虽如此，前提是，你知道的，等你下次票房惨败的时候，我一定会第一个跳出来说：你扑街了。好吧，你猜怎么着？我们还没聊《热血男儿》的票房呢。我们刚才直接把这茬给跳过去了。哦，我们没聊那个。对，确实如此。
You know when you set out to make a cult classic on a studio's dime? It's because I was in it. I'm box office boys at that. Not true. Andy, thank you, my friend. Thanks for being here. We appreciate it. We appreciate it.
你知道当你试图用制片厂的钱去打造一部邪典经典时是怎样的吗？那是因为我在里面。我可是票房保障啊，小伙子们。才怪。安迪，谢谢你，我的朋友。谢谢你来到这里。我们感激不尽。我们感激不尽。
Thank you guys. You're the greatest. Yeah, keep on keeping on. You are this. And let's just be friends now and hang out, Jason. It's done. It's done. You can't shake me now. We'll find a time and just do it. I'll put you guys in touch.
谢谢你们。你们是最棒的。对，继续坚持下去。你就是这样。我们现在就做朋友吧，以后常聚聚，杰森。就这么定了。就这么定了。你现在甩不掉我了。我们会找个时间把这事定了。我来把你们拉个群。
Please do. Yes, please. I will. Definitely will. Okay. And Sean. Love you. Love you, Sean. Bye, guys. I mean, when I say guys, I mean... See you, bud. Bop a booey. Bop a...
请务必。好的，拜托了。我会的。一定会的。好的。还有肖恩。爱你。爱你，肖恩。再见，伙计们。我是说，当我说是伙计们的时候，我指的是……再见，兄弟。巴巴布伊。巴巴……
Fafafoo-hi. Fafafoo-fly. Wait, what's Bop a boo. Bop a fu high. Bop a flu fly. Wait, what's Bop a buoy? Gary Dillebate from Howard Stern. Oh yeah, Bop a buoy, that's right. Bop a buoy. So, keep it real up in the field, alright? I would love to.
法法富嗨。法法富飞。等等，什么是“巴巴布伊”？巴巴富嗨。巴巴弗鲁飞。等等，什么是“巴巴布伊”？霍华德·斯特恩节目里的加里·迪尔贝特。哦对，巴巴布伊，没错。巴巴布伊。所以，在现实生活中保持真我，好吗？我很愿意。
I would. I would love to. So guys, that was Andy Samberg. Yes, he was fantastic. He's the greatest. The greatest, he created his own lane. And he's my new friend. Yeah, he's your new friend.
我愿意。我非常愿意。所以伙计们，刚才那位就是安迪·萨姆伯格。是的，他太棒了。他最棒了。最棒的，他开辟了自己的赛道。而且他成了我的新朋友。对，他成了你的新朋友。
And he doesn't really, yeah, he's stuck with me now. He doesn't realize it yet, but it's gonna be a problem for him. He's the real deal, and as I said, again, at risk of embarrassing him, he is such a good guy and he totally deserves it. He's just one of the good dudes. Kind, sweet, yeah. For sure.
而且他其实——对，他现在被我赖上了。他自己还没意识到，但这对他来说将是个麻烦。他是个货真价实的好人，正如我刚才所说，冒着让他尴尬的风险，他真的是个绝顶好人，这一切都是他应得的。他就是那种真正的好小伙。善良、贴心，对。确实如此。
And everybody agrees, everybody can agree, that everybody loves Andy Samberg. Yeah, that's a good name for his TV show. Everybody loves Andy. Everybody can agree, and everybody agrees, that everybody loves Andy Samberg. There you go. That's a good tune. There you go. It's a good tune.
大家都赞同，所有人都会同意，每个人都爱安迪·萨姆伯格。对，这名字挺适合他的电视节目。每个人都会同意，而且大家都赞同，每个人都爱安迪·萨姆伯格。瞧。这曲调挺顺的。瞧。这曲调挺顺的。
There you go. Yeah, he's extra special. I love everything he does. Always good and everything he does. Good guest. And I'm excited to hear their new podcast that those guys are doing with Seth because I love hearing how they put together each one of those digital shorts. I love that they're like, it was last minute, they needed something.
瞧。对，他格外特别。我喜欢他做的每一件事。他做的每件事总是那么棒。很好的嘉宾。我很期待听到他们跟塞思一起制作的新播客，因为我超爱听他们是如何把每一个数字短片拼凑起来的。我喜欢他们说那是最后一分钟才决定、临时缺个节目的时候——
Yes, I love all that stuff. Right? I love that stuff. And I think he could, for the Lonely Island, for, last minute, they needed something. Yes, I love all that stuff. I love that stuff. And I think for the Lonely Island guys, they created this brand and this company and this thing that's really awesome and cool and stays like real smart and real funny always. What? No, I have nothing. But if I did have something, it would be... It would go like this.
对，我喜欢所有这些内幕。对吧？我喜欢这些。而且我觉得对于寂寞岛的这帮人来说，他们创造了这个品牌、这家公司以及这一切，真的非常棒、非常酷，而且永远保持着真正的聪明和真正的幽默。什么？不，我没什么要说的。但如果我非要说点什么的话，那就是……它会是这样的。
It would go... It would reference Howard Stern and I would have something, it would be... It would go like this. It would go... It would reference Howard Stern, and I would say something like... Bye bye, Bowie! Bowie! Bye bye, Bowie! Bye bye, Bowie! Close enough. Smart.
它会是……它会致敬霍华德·斯特恩，如果我要说点什么，它会是这样的。它会是……它会致敬霍华德·斯特恩，我会说类似这样的话……拜拜，鲍伊！鲍伊！拜拜，鲍伊！拜拜，鲍伊！差不多得了。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
精简。聪明。精简。聪明。精简。聪明。精简。
Less. Smart. Less. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico and Michael Granteri. SmartLess. If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Nancy's love story could have been ripped right out of the pages of one of her own novels. She was a romance mystery writer who happens to be married to a chef.
精简。SmartLess由罗布·阿尔梅杰夫、贝内特·巴尔比科和迈克尔·格兰特里100%有机纯手工打造。SmartLess。如果你喜欢SmartLess，现在就可以加入Wondry App或苹果播客上的Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告版。在离开之前，请填写Wondry.com/survey上的简短问卷，让我们更好地了解你。南希的爱情故事简直就像是从她自己的一部小说里撕下来的。她是一位浪漫悬疑小说家，恰好嫁给了一位厨师。
But this story didn't end with a happily ever after. When I stepped into the kitchen, I could see that Chef Brophy was on the ground and I heard somebody say, call 911. As writers, we'd written our share of murder mysteries. So when suspicion turned to Dan's wife, Nancy, we weren't that surprised. The first person they'd look at would be the spouse.
但这个故事并没有以幸福美满结局。当我走进厨房时，我看到布罗菲主厨倒在地上，我听到有人喊，快叫911。作为作家，我们写过不少谋杀悬疑小说。所以当嫌疑转向丹的妻子南希时，我们并没有那么惊讶。他们首先调查的对象肯定就是配偶。
We understand that's usually the way they do it. But we began to wonder, had Nancy gotten so wrapped up in her own novels... There are murders in all of the books. ...that she was playing them out in real life? Follow Happily Never After, Dan and Nancy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge all episodes of Happily Never After, Dan and Nancy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们知道他们通常都是这么干的。但我们开始纳闷，难道南希已经深陷于自己的小说中无法自拔……所有的书里都有谋杀案。……以至于她在现实生活中上演了这些情节？在Wondry App或你获取播客的任何地方收听《幸福从未降临：丹与南希》。现在加入Wondry Plus，即可抢先无广告畅听《幸福从未降临：丹与南希》的所有单集。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。